welcome to the fword on the menu tonight
for our main course of roast is peasant
with bra cabbage and bread sauce it's
sah Bean's chocolate brownie recipe
better than mine I desperately
desperately desperately need to win
trust me it's time to get the kids ready
to say goodbye to the turkeys we're
eating them
Christmas and Big Brother's deina mcco
is in for dinner did you just say the
word sex in my ear you can't do things
like that to
me the was my mother and C my that I
love my mother and I love my dad want to
have all that I never had the was here
the C my mother and my dad that I love
my mother and I love my dad want to have
all that
[Music]
never okay guys yes are we ready yes
Carrie you ready yeah serious face on
yeah let's let's go okay on order six
covers table to six Haro bean soup make
or six pheasants let's go pheasants in
please let's go now tonight start is a
rich Sumptuous Haro bean soup with tiger
prawns now these beans have been soaked
overnight in water and what that does it
actually softens the bean and makes them
cook a lot
quicker in with the bacon onion and
carrot and once you brought it to the
boow quickly cook out for about 25 to 30
minutes
Now Tiger prawns has its own built-in
cooking gauge when they're raw they're
gray when they're cooked they're nice
and pink we cook the prawns for 30
seconds in boiling water and vegetables
we call that a c bullion now prawns are
the perfect choice for a seafood
beginner because they're nice and sweet
slightly meaty and so easy to
cook we peel them from the shell when
they're warm because it's a lot easier
when they're warm get the tail and push
with your finger them from and the whole
thing just pops out once the beans have
been drained of it stock just take a
couple of handfuls out cuz that's going
to be in with the prawns and the
mushrooms at the bottom of the soup the
rest of the beans into the
[Music]
mixer couple of ladles of bean puree
into the
pan we add our chicken stock and bring
it up to the boil once we start to boil
it we're going to add a touch of
cream now this comes with the boil for
the exciting part is where we start to
froth the soup and make it really nice
and
light bit of a chef's thing you don't
have to fro it up but it's just a way of
making it a little bit lighter and if
you don't have a stick mix then just
serve it as a normal white bean soup
nothing wrong with it whatsoever that's
it okay go take your Ladle out give it a
little
buzz car give the BL out oh come on man
now tonight in the kitchen my three Comm
chefs are Phil Russell and krie they've
already survive one round in the fword
kitchen and whoever stays tonight will
come back to battle it out for a job in
one of my restaurants okay why are we
making two pant I want three portions
the soups made to order you've got four
portions there he's got four portions
why don't you do the garnish yeah yeah
and you do the soup but no one's talking
and you're just making no sense
whatsoever so talk to one
another check the season please taste it
car come
on
and an set the garage up here an so we
can start soing yes Gordon yeah yeah
that's out this table yes
Gordon the garnish for the soup are the
tiger prawns along with the tiger prawns
we've got these little Japanese samuji
mushrooms and we're just going to so do
the mushrooms off get your cloth on the
front here that's
it
okay get some color on the mushrooms
first before you put the prawns
in now we're using a Japanese mushroom
but to be quite Frank any mushroom will
work lovely with this 30 seconds for the
prawns get your beans put your beans in
with the prawns and there we
have a really nice garnish right now
this soed off the garnish yes just
season it with some fresh parley yeah we
put in just listen to me shut up and
just listen that's all if you listen
you're going to do well but fresh
parsley then from there over to the Bowl
let's
go okay take your garnish
and be generous with the garnish your
prawns your beans and your mushrooms
into the plate now just three portions
come on Carrie please wake up just three
portions one two three you're on your
fourth B sorry sorry
G so you take half the froth and half
the soup and you pour it gently over the
garnish yeah and then you go back to the
beginning yeah and put a little bit more
froth on there can you just concentrate
for me yeah and try to wake up a little
bit it'll make life a lot easier for you
for you the customers and me yes yes
good girl it's not difficult you know
that I know now this is a perfect winter
soup great for the cold nights ahead and
check out the fword website for the
recipe service
please
you well it it was delicious soup the
porns I'm not sure how they were cooked
but they had a beautiful flavor thumbs
up to Gordon really I'm afraid sorry big
sucker but absolutely he's gorgeous and
so's his food so what what more can I
say that's why it was easier ladies good
evening hello how are you to see yeah
very One D thank you I love watching you
in there how was your soup it was very
very good yes yes very thank you no I
love rich food do you cook at home I
sort of share it because we've got
little kids so whoever puts the kids to
bed doesn't do the cooking really I'm
quite good with the with the recipe yep
but I'm not my husband's got the flare I
haven't got the flare and what would you
say his Pier the resistance is what's
his favorite dish um my favorite dish
that he does is it's um just sea bass
baked sea bass and he he um does sort of
some grilled vegetables and then he'll
put them in the tray with the seat bass
open the foil and put it in sounds a
little bit like Jamie Oliver to me that
one no is he using is that a swear word
we not say that you're not on a
particular diet or anything like that
are you no I don't no how do you keep so
fit work out work out I mean I basically
eat what I want yeah um because I work
out and that's one very good reason to
work out isn't it so you can eat what
you want yeah EXA but have you ever been
on a diet I did that did the work
brilliantly I lost6 in 2 weeks amazing
but I was obsessed by bread like if
somebody picked up that piece of bread
over there I'd see you at 500 paces and
I'd be like oh my God they're eing bread
you know and then I'd say okay I'll have
Sundays off so I'd start eating sweets
and bread at 7: in the morning and I'd
literally be like
P you know until the end of the day it
was just ridiculous there is one
negativity against the sort of accus
diet yeah cuz it's not very good for
your sex life you say the word sex in my
ear you said the word sex in my ear does
it have in my ear like you can't do
things like that to me oh I'll tell you
what it did
have well I couldn't poo I mean if
you're going to say sex let's say poo I
couldn't poo for AG because it was awful
because you don't e vegetables and with
that hello heinous breath so obviously
sex life is going to go out the window
because you can't snog and if you can't
snog you're not going to have sex you
took me there Gordon next on the menu
along with our main course of pheasant
with a fantastic breed
sauce the commies start to crack Under
Pressure you're going to kill someone
you can't serve raw bacon and just when
I thought things couldn't get any worse
for jles Corin we sent him down a sewer
Chefs of the world would love to see me
disappear under
[Applause]
there
okay 1 minute for the Cabbage how long
for you an 1 minute please 1 minute
let's go you can start pling up in 30
seconds yes welcome back to the f word
time now for the main course roasted
pheasant braed cabbage bread sauce with
Devils on
Horseback
pheasant the secret behind cooking this
bird is actually lining the breast with
some streaky bacon cuz it really is a
very lean bird with hardly any fat
tight not too tight a it keeps the bacon
on and B actually keeps the bird in a
really good shape hot pan olive
oil
season
time peasant nice hot pan saky bacon thy
straight into the
oven red
sauce thy salt pepper
Blitz hot P
butter onion on the heat cloves Starnes
bay leaf the Big Daddy black pepper pull
in the china shop this is the one that
actually brings it all
together
sweat
milk let it Infuse bring it to the bow
slowly back to
Pheasant base that keeps the Pheasant
really nice and moist finish the
sauce C that milk is amazing bread
crumbs
in butter now we have a really nice
smooth smart sexy bread
sauce I okay feasant rest 15 minutes and
turn it upside down CU all the juices
from the top of the carcass run into the
bottom of the bread rest and so by the
time it's cooled down it's full of
[Music]
flavor the whole leg just Falls
away
delicious pheasant with red
sauce
done now with the Pheasant I'm also
serving some red cabbage and we we all
grew up with this stuff pickled in a jar
but this is done in a very simple form
it started on top of the stove it's got
butter in with it and then we season it
with brown sugar over the cabbage and
then tablespoon of
vinegar add that to the brown sugar salt
pepper and then we braze it in the oven
for about 45 to 50 minutes so it Cooks
nice and slowly absorbs the vinegar the
sugar caramelizes it and makes it a
really nice tasty
cabbage now I'm serving devils and
horseback with a pheasant and that's
basically a prune that's been wrapped in
bacon the
sweetness and the saltiness of the bacon
goes brilliantly with a pheasant
cocktail stick keep the bacon on there
into a pan get some really good color on
the bacon gets nice and crispy and that
crispy bacon with a sweet prune is
amazing now don't forget to take the
cocktail sticks out before you serve
them there it is yeah five peasant one
Ravi yeah journalist table watch that
table Liz J journalist so the Pheasant
first then revoli okay okay be very very
careful yeah now earlier today I set the
is a challenge and that was to try and
separate the men from the
boys challenge time we got a table of
vegetarians in this evening now
vegetarian food has to be as just as
exciting as the normal menu so on this
table in front of us we've got an array
of vegetables I want you to think of a
vegetarian filling for a ravioli think
about it spinach ricotta sood mushrooms
rocket basil you know just have a look
you got half an hour let's go
[Music]
yes
what's going to in your mind what are
you doing cheese work at dog at the same
time we're against the clock like a
fully booked restaurant yes not just
about your cheese tomato so what are you
going to do cheese tomato Moz mozard
okay that okay yeah that sounds nice and
you're going to season it with fresh
Basel yeah Basel hurry up
yes right Russell what are you doing I'm
thinking of a open top ravioli open top
ravioli nice and what's in the open top
ravioli
right I'm thinking sundried Tomatoes Y
and then I've also got uh roasted pepper
going on there just give it that flavor
just get get it going I'm going to put
some blue cheese into it as well blue
cheese as well yeah and as you know we
haven't got all day you know that yeah
okay so move your ass yeah y yeah sure
okay
Phil what are you going to do I'm going
to do a tomato and Basel with a buffalo
mozzarella okay and you put the
mozzarella in when it's cooled down so
it doesn't melt so it doesn't melt so we
can just keep those that's that solid
cubes there yeah so as it starts to cook
in the raviola it just slightly melts
inside okay
good looks like something out of a
sci-fi
movie A Taste KN well we'll find out
won't we
[Music]
s okay guys that's it let's go carry on
the hot plake Russell let's go Phil
Carrie there come on stand next to it
right uh
Russell pasta Stone Cold you didn't even
heat the pasta up Chef Phil he started
blanching his pasta and you followed
suit rather than you're remaining as an
individual cuz your filling look nice
unfortunately so far I've got stone cold
pasta overcooked pasta let's hope the
last one at least had got
something what's that the raw Sage leave
yeah yeah it went I no yeah we only put
on a plate what we can eat yeah never
forget that and look at that you can see
why I don't change nappies inpd Bland
and nothing what I asked for a simple
ravioli unfortunately I'm not going to
serve any of them in the restaurant by
vegetarians you know that tonight get
your [__] together yeah clear
down right let's go carry please yes
four pheasant away now yes four pheasant
away now let's yeah oh yeah I don't
understand what you're doing car you're
dropping your spoon you're putting it
back in your pocket come on let's
go let's go need any more on me no why
are you asking me when you putting it on
come on cuz I think we do peasant please
now present come on this is where it's
getting really tough now yes y down
let's
go here it's not cooked it's raw oh the
Bacon's Raw for God's
sake Carrie come here a minute you it's
raw it is raw young lady you're going to
kill someone you can't serve raw bacon
not good enough not good enough take
your Aon off and go forget it out right
and start the table again please God's
sake and start the table again
now it will soon be time to slaughter
the turkey so I've been trying to get
the kids ready to say
goodbye we're a week away from
slaughtering the turkeys the children
have been fattening up for Christmas I'm
getting worried that the kids are
getting too attached oh well done let's
have a look is that Anthony Tilly loves
cuddling Anthony and Megan's been
keeping her own video diary D have been
even more grumpy than yesterday I asked
Janice Horton Wallace from the turkey
club UK how to deal with it her
suggestion was rather
radical you may have to
consider possibly just keeping a couple
back so that then they they they think
well okay yeah those go but we will
still have some turkeys here will we get
any turkey eggs they start um mating
properly in January or February and then
the girls usually start laying eggs
about 4 weeks after the mating process
they're very good layers and the eggs
are wonderful in baking really oh they
are definitely worth trying like a duck
egg or they're not as strong as a duck
egg but slightly larger than a chicken's
egg but they uh because of the extra
album they're very good in pastry
sources and things like that and what
about her indoors I got to explain that
to her oh she'll love eating their eggs
I'm not that convinced and I don't think
Tana will be very enthusiastic either
she mentioned if the kids are getting
really sort of attached there is a
strong possibility we could keep them or
maybe keep half of them and cook half I
think we've always been very honest with
them and this is what's happening and I
think they are prepared for that and we
stick to what we originally planned I'm
you know happy to go along with what we
set out to do but I'm just asking you to
think about an alternative we've done
your project I've supported you in that
we fattened up the turkeys and now
you're backtracking cuz you like them de
is shaking cuz you're shouting so you're
upsetting let me go and sit over with
her you go sit with de Can't Believe
come on De come on there have been times
when it's really driven me crazy having
the is here all the mess and everything
like that but it's been a fantastic
learning curve for the
children we've only got a couple of days
left of the turkeys and then they're
going to be slaughtered so I thought
let's throw a turkey party they can
explain to their friends exactly what's
going on and also it'll really put it
clear in their minds that this is
happening and they won't sort of wake up
surprised to know that it's the final
day we're eating them for Christmas
which one are you going to eat first for
dinner we're going to eat one that
oh you're really shocked you're going to
kill all of them you're going to kill
Jack's turkey first yeah you so fat the
kids actually seem fine about killing
the birds but I need to know whether
I've got enough turkey to feed the
diners at the restaurant so Peter the
vet's going to do a final weigh in what
are we
doing why so we can find out if they're
fat fat how fat they are we want them
very fat for Christmas don't we that six
kilos yeah
you need help lifting that one up wait
wait wait wait
wait
14 okay who's got the
[Music]
balance
10 who's next
[Music]
Gia why do I always catch the TB you're
very good at
this
all right Angley I know seven kilos
yeah who would like a
[Music]
[Applause]
sandwich can't do that Matt how are you
evening shf good to see you good to see
you too not only a wine writer but
you're actually Jamie Oliver's Samilia y
you're his wine waiter at 15 yep now you
bought some
AB going go well know please tell me
they're not all Australian not there's
not one Australian Australian but do you
know what I think when it comes to kind
of food and wine matching um you know I
think a lot of people kind of get
unnecessarily kind of you know confused
with it and stressed with it and they
they tend to think that you know the
best matches end up being you know the
most expensive matches and it's not
always the case definitely definitely
and um here I mean this is the one word
to describe this one is that it's sexy
you know sexy you get kind of that sort
of um dark cherry get dark cherry you
get a little bit of spice but straight
away you're getting things like cinnamon
cloves you know stares all the kind of
things that you use when you were
cooking the Pheasant out there all those
kind of ingredients are starting to come
through and I guess that's one of the
key things when it comes to food and
wine matching you want to look for kind
of like similar sort of waste between
food and wine you also want to look a
similar similar kind of intensity of
flavor and keep it sexy absolutely now
um you're highly competitive yes I am
I'm going a test for you okay three of
the most extraordinary wines I want you
to try and tell me what you think they
are here we go I'm not saying
[Applause]
anything he going to be something like
Blue Nun 5 quid
under mate 5 pound on under absolutely
on the nose Blue
Nun well
done one of my
favorites the heat is on big
boy you should always trust your first
instincts and for me like first thing I
sort of smell is kind
of Cedar you know it's it's got there's
a fair bit of Oak in there there's a
fair bit of fruit weight as well um dark
Plum dark fruit you know straight away
I'm kind of thinking Big Rich full body
great variety probably thinking new
world as well so really okay it
taste
huh now the heat is on and you can see
he's looking nervous come on that's
turbocharged there's some weight muscle
and intensity behind that that's that's
kind of like it's awesome shazo cabinet
from probably from
Australia here we
go well done did I say awesome sh well
done awesome sh well done thanks very
much huh fantastic great okay you ready
yeah I'm
[Laughter]
ready okay instantly what you think what
when I look at this wine well I'm I'm
I'm noticing the color the color is
nowhere near near as deep as the as the
previous one sight's kind of probably
the least important of all your three
senses you know yeah I mean you can
close your eyes
and that's how I always find it a lot
easier what are you getting's we talking
about a very different league right
between that wine and this wine okay so
it's not giving away much on the nose
it's pretty flat pretty dull
uhhuh soft simple it's even a little bit
corked Gordon I can't believe you put on
a wine that's just a I would not do that
to you come on you think that's it's
just a little bit CED I'm not going to
argue with you but I mean I don't mind
fighting but that's definitely not cked
you do the cooking I'll do the
wine oh God taxi okay have a little
taste God it's probably going to be
amazing Bordeaux or something like that
isn't it 32 one what's the answer it's
Bordeaux it's cavana Bas one from bord
uhhuh yeah what would you pay for it how
much would you pay for that 30 40 quid
30 40 quid you've been eating far too
many kangaroos you know that that was a
,000 bottle of
petruse
goodness
I told Matthew for goodness sake 1,000
Li truth 1992 my oh it's 9 it's 92 well
look you know I'm Australian I have
cheap taste [__] was it was it meatloaf
that said two out of three Ain bad next
on the menu it's pudding time Sarah
beanie takes me on with a chocolate
brownie also I think that pudding nuts
in it it's a bit like putting leaks and
macaroni cheese oh really so it's just
wrong J's goes in the sewer a it's
disappearing into human [__] and deina
has to sing for her
supper just an old sweet
song keeps
Georgia on My
[Applause]
Mind okay uh Phil Russell come here yeah
one's gone yeah yes we tried to put raw
bacon on a plate now my Brigade are
leaving and you two are going to run the
f word restaurant you've got a table of
four and you got a table of four yes hey
everything from bread sauce to Cabbage
to Pheasant yeah Mark out and out Neil
bye-bye let's go come on Russell wakey
wakey Bacon's burning she's already gone
home on the back of that let's go come
on Big
Boy nice and crispy little touch of
butter in there fill to finish it off
with yeah Phil you got table 10 ready
Chef yes and Russell you got table 14
yes yes chef well you know was talking
to one another hello we're in the same
restaurant you ready R yeah how long you
got I'm ready mate you're here move
let's
go yeah I'm looking for presentation
yeah each and every plate looking
exactly the same let's go standby table
14 standby look at each other's plates
check that we' got the same things going
on the same size portions yes yeah come
on don't forget it's the same restaurant
yes come on phant on first they're last
that's the garnish yes there you go
think about what you're
doing come on Russell yes chef put the
tray down work with two hands it's twice
as quick yes voila right take your time
don't spoil it now yes gently gently
gently let's go are you happy dirty
plate I'm not happy with that hair there
on the Pheasant pull it out come on wake
up you got four eyes let's go up go
table four 14
go M come here both of you well done
that's what it's like in the real world
that's one table each out of 20 tonight
clear down start again well done yes
sure hello there nice to see you how are
you yeah very well thank you how are you
good very well you enjoyed the peasant
yes I did enjoy the peasant although
I've got something for you here there's
a bit of shots that's great news yeah so
it was mean that one of those Posh Birds
is a real bird amazing
yeah the combination of everything was
really good but the the Pheasant was
just cooked to Perfection absolute
perfection really
lovely how are you yeah well thank you
good to see you nice to see you how was
The Peasant it was very nice yes very
nice I could have been a little bit more
veg I felt goo dare well I'm just saying
you don't need more veg with that phant
and Devils on Horseback and the bread
sauce and the bra the Devils on
Horseback were were pretty superb
wonderful the way that it was cooked
this evening was fantastic it fell off
the bone and the fact that the plate
itself isn't actually loaded with with
Superfluous vegetables as well made it
very very nice time for pudding this
week Sarah Bean is going to try and beat
me with her favorite dessert chocolate
brownie now there's 100 recipes of
chocolate brownies and I'm doing
something quite sort of U unique
Sumptuous delicious we're finishing it
this time with some little peans but
this is not a big tray of chocolate
brownie they're going to be done in
little bleen pans we're going to but of
them line them with chocolate and cook
them individually almost like a little
sort of pancake but pancake chocolate
brownie this is a children's chocolate
brownie cuz I don't think you should put
extra bits in it should just be pure
chocolate brownie this is really cheap
so you can make it if you're having
masses of people to a
party you can make it for loads of
people we had it at our wedding actually
not that I'm a cheap skate or anything
so get your brush and lightly brush the
inside of the pan now all it is is a
block of chocolate
break it in half and just
great and just pour the chocolate in
there and then roll it round right Sarah
how are we doing this is cocoa sugar and
flour yep and then this is the eggs and
you just pour in and there and that's it
that's it yeah it tastes great I'm sure
it does now no chocolate in there no no
it's got It's got cocoa powder just
cocoa powder yeah and then I have to
grease the tin and that looks like
something you've nicked from your granny
um yeah that's the G and that goes in
there and how long does that cook for 25
minutes or maybe a bit more if it
doesn't look cooked cuz it should be
nice and crispy on the outside and soft
and gooy G that's the word you're a lady
who likes pressure you got 37 guests
coming around on boxing day Christmas
Day Christmas day that's a big table
that 37 that is a big table and you're
going cooking not single-handedly surely
well sort of single-handed I've got this
turkey that's kind of huge huge so have
you got lots of Christmas I think we've
got about um 18 or 20 hey that's just as
bad I know crazy is do you do lots of
entertaining then I'm not very good at
the dinner party thing you know that
it's not the kind of thing I U I really
enjoy doing to be totally honest so this
is why I couldn't be a cook cuz I think
this is taking ages and it's really
boring I'm thinking God hurry up how do
you know so much about property I've got
a building company I do a boy job you
see you do a girls job I do a boy job I
do a girls job yeah that's the whole
grive I wish women would get back in
there and do their job I you know that
women do make the best chefs you know
that I know we OB viously women do
everything best no no no not quite
everything hello not quite everything
you're a bit of a Matchmaker aren't you
I am it is a bit of an obsession of M
always has been actually which serious
now did you do that over food yeah well
the best place to meet someone is over
food and booze isn't it food and booze
yes yeah stick food and booze and a few
single people together and they're going
to get married and what about someone
like our resident food critic I mean is
there is a woman out there that's mad
enough to sort of date him how would you
despite him Moy wiy beardy short ass I
think he definitely get someone he
definitely get flipping EG now the
chocolate and the butter has melted I've
whisked the eggs lightly I folded them
in Sarah is going to be S of gunge in
the center she said sounds very ominous
um and mine of course is going to be
lined with like chocolate buttons and
these little things peans I have to say
at this stage without getting too
carried away a damsite more appetizing
than
Sarah's mind you I said that about the
Trifles last week as well didn't I also
I think that putting nuts in it is a bit
like putting leaks in macaroni cheese oh
really so it's just wrong it's ruining
the Purity I'm now just going to lift
that out and put them in to the molds
and then hopefully we'll be ready so
when you fill the mold up 2/3 because
they're going to rise slightly and then
we leave it nice and soft and gooey in
the center those chocolate buttons
hopefully will be intact but slightly
runny I could have refurbished a five
bedroom house and the time it takes to
melts the butter like how frustrating
this some's going to eat it and you just
got washing up to do whilst you're U
pregnant okay and obviously my wife been
pregnant three times I put weight on to
make her feel happy does it happen the
same with your husband sweet te does he
put weight on to make you feel of he is
actually less fat in
bed no he does still say good God you're
fat every time I have no clothes on
serious so which is true to be honest no
you going to stay confident now cuz it's
not cooked now let me have a quick look
at yours okay just like the bike shares
you can look at mine let me look at
yours yeah cheeky that's nice I've got
to say your yours does look like you
cook for a living mine does look like I
don't and I desperately desperately
desperately need to win you need to win
okay here we go it'll taste great though
um I'm sure it will you know
[Applause]
that hello Charles hello Gordon are you
well I'm I'm not bad at all I'm happy at
least I've been fed you've been fed now
what you been up to this week um I've
been down a sewer um I'm so used to
healthy hygienic places like
professional kitchens God bins squirrels
kebabs and but no but that that was cuz
I was investigating food here I was
investigating quite the opposite I was I
was up to my up to my elbows in uh in
[__] yeah and it's because of the fat
that gets thrown
away fat is a huge problem in Britain
I'm not talking about fat people I'm
talking about cooking fat when you flush
them away down the sewers as we all do
sometimes they'll cool solidify and
Harden and cause blockages and when that
happens we're in big
trouble last year alone we spent 15
million clearing our pipes and 3,000
properties were flooded as a result of
blockage with Christmas approaching the
water companies are expecting a 25%
increase in the amount of fat that we're
flushing down our drains which means
that we're going to be adding over
Christmas to an already existing problem
in the underbelly of our cities but what
does that really mean I'm not dressed up
like this just cuz it looks sexy it's
cuz I'm going to go down there and find
out well I I understand the issues about
this fat being thrown away but it looks
all fairly harmless when it goes down
the sink so what does it look like here
I don't understand well you'll soon see
JS when you get around this corner
here oh it smells nasty now if I drown
or something you going do mouth to mouth
you won't drown what's this that's uh
that's the fat what you're going to go
into that's fat yeah it's fat that's fat
out of people's kitchen gone down the
sink and yeah oh no no and there's
things living in it a [__] and it's
everywhere cheers for it so I need a
radioactive anti thingy death suit just
be careful oh God the chefs of the world
who would love to see me disappear under
there a it's disappearing into human
[__] it's some sanitary to why am I
doing this I don't
know there it is that's your fat that's
your turkey roast your lovely Granny's
and grandchildren come around and you
cook that up for them and you toss it
down the sink without a thought he comes
down here solidifies people like Kenny
have to walk up and down and they
shoveling it up and throwing it away
it's absolutely disgusting I'm I'm I'm I
probably knew that already I didn't need
to come down here to prove but we'll do
it
[Music]
again well this is the third shower that
I've had since I got back from the sewer
and I haven't got close to removing the
smell having seen the scale of the
problem though I promise you I'm
determined to find out what we can do
about it so I discovered a clever little
device you can use at home fat traps
which is a thing like this that you
leave by the sink instead of throwing
your used fat down the sink you just
pour it into there in this manner you
put some nuts in it you give it a shake
to make a lovely little feast and you
put it out for the birds or in fact if
you haven't got one of those you can do
the same thing with a with a baked bean
here apparently if we all do this if we
all use these fat traps and stop
throwing our stuff down the sinks we can
make a huge difference to the state of
our sewers and drains having said that
restaurants and fast food joints are the
biggest fatty villains and they also
need to shape up by law they're obliged
to have waste fat collected although
thousands of them are still illegally
pouring it down the
drain but some councils are fighting
back they're collecting the fat for free
and turning it into diesel for cars so
I've got a gallon here of delightful
waste cooking oil from the fword
restaurant which I brought into my
garden because it's the last thing I
want in my house uh because I've got a
fellow here who reckons he can turn it
into uh into car fuel yeah what we're
doing is we're convert it into biodiesel
and so how much will our gallon of fword
waste cooking fat make how much diesel
one gallon of used cooking oil you'll
get one gallon of biodiesel so do you
need to do anything to the engine of
your car to make this stuff work in it
if you've got a properly produced
biodiesel it it's a direct replacement
you don't have to modify things you're
saying I just throw into the drum this
used fat yeah literally pour it in
slightly Green Oh and then I just hit
hit this this green button here pump on
correct is that it that's as easy as no
I need to add cotic soda and methanol
okay ducky so I pop that in the hopper
here and start pumping the methanol over
and how long does this take to make
takes about an hour mixing and and it's
that easy and then hey Presto we have
biodiesel hey Presto you have biodiesel
pumping into your car and you can drive
off
and here it comes real diesel although
that said uh I think I'm first going to
have to put in the car and go for a
drive just to make absolutely sure it
works you think I can just put this
straight in a cardi just pour it
straight in in it
goes righty then it's the moment of
truth will the car
start hrah it has I didn't believe it
would it's amazing smells a smells more
like a chip shop than a car though um I
have a a gallon of Gordon's used fat in
this car and given that it's as good as
diesel uh that will get me if I head
north from my home as far as Luton well
lucky
[Applause]
me excited yeah yeah this is going to be
fantastic this is uh I'm actually
slightly nervous oh no is it burnt oh no
it's got a nice crack on the top okay
now how you going to serve yours I'm
going to serve it in slices like a cake
you just won't you know send it like
that and give them a
spoon yes but the difficulty is you have
to make them with all sort of Posh stuff
in don't you not at all chocolate
buttons that's not Posh finish mine with
a touch of creeme fresh this is called a
blob that's called a blob nice are you
happy with that John Baptist um take
Sarah upstairs first okay yes yes and if
they don't like it we can line they LOF
with some new cavity wall installation
okay yeah can I just say it's bloody
heavy honestly it feels like one of your
breeze blocks from one of your
buildings hello how are you guys hello
so this is number
one I like the texture on the top as
well like kind of crunch it's kind of
nice and gooey in the middle and it's
like nice kind of crunchy outside it
does kind of it just drapes of your
tongue doesn't it the choc bit feeling
might might be slightly too gooey
actually just if I was going to add some
constructive criticism to that but but I
find it I quite like the gooiness just
cuz makes it quite contrast from the the
crust okay then this is this is number
two okay thank you
wellow I'm not sure about this one I'm
not sure about the cream yeah it's the
cream it's quite dry actually isn't it's
quite flaky on the
top I shouldn't be overconfident about
you know the brownies at this stage but
I have to say I bloody am you know that
cuz if I lose this challenge this week
honestly say I I will start liking Andre
R Thompson that's how confident I am I'm
going to win
yeah I think I've had enough of that one
yeah Alie JB Al so this week the winner
is yes well done sah oh get out will
pissing around oh no Sarah won I'll get
out really sorry the result you know
that I'm going to go upstairs and see
the judges where are
they yeah I'm glad you find it funny um
just out of Interest I mean taste that
again for me okay yeah all of you and
then I can start with the lady in the
end now tell me what
you tasting tastes bitter bitter yeah
kind of like almost burnt taste to it
burnt look how look just look how wet
that is in the center in the middle but
you're going to get through the dry
outside to get to the
middle I I you know I I don't understand
it just slightly too
dry sorry all three of you can off out
of here now as well yes dear oh
dear useless I'm not going to serve it
I'm going to serve my chocolate brownie
my restaurant my customers and and and
my reputation on the line that's that
and that's it that is fair enough I'm
really sorry but no it is okay cuz you
do think this is poo don't you no it's
just it you know it's not nice it's not
bad but it's not good come here let me
get around that bump oh I'm sent out
here like this well done well done next
on the menu I rediscovered Britain's
most underrated but delicious meat M
it's by you I'd have it any day and Phil
and Russell find out which one of them
is staying and who's going home one of
you is a follower and one of you is a
[Applause]
Creator right Sarah yes I know it's not
your dessert but you can still get the
pan do you want me to pick the nuts out
make it better I don't mind you picking
my nuts at all for God's sake we like a
knife so do yeah it stuck you see mine
didn't stick
so send that to J please now my god oh
gosh it's quite nice you got to wash
your hands now you know that we get so
complaints yeah oh no look at the
buttons in mine yeah see disappointing
really isn't it I'm glad you think so
thanks so
much chocolate Bry with creem fresh can
you just say that for me one more time
Chate chocolate BR with cream fresh what
oh my God that was so cute a chocolate
Bry
ladies enjoy your chocolate
brownie very very suck and lovely kind
of dessert you want to take the bed
right perfect I can tell you on the
outside and soft on the inside and you
got a little bit of chocolate dripping
down here and it's perfect this week
I'll be looking at one of Britain's
tastiest but sadly most unfashionable
Meats Once Upon a Time mutton was a very
reasonably priced meat that everyone ate
before it fell off the kitchen radar and
not not only don't want to see it back
in restaurants back on their menus but
at home as well because this is part of
our culinary
Heritage mutton is a meat from a sheep
that's at least 2 years old it's rarely
sold in supermarkets and can be hard to
get your hands on these days most of our
mutton gets eaten in Europe when was the
last time you at mutton years ago years
ago and who cooked it my grandmother
it's a bit sort of oldfashioned and a
bit it's not very sort of sexy is it
mutton I've never eaten mutton at all
ever cheap cut of meat most people now
earn more money they buy better cuts of
meat it looks like mutton's been
completely forgotten so what did mutton
disappear totally Financial in the
1940s the imports from um Australia New
Zealand came um the price of lamb and
wool went down and it wasn't worth
Farmers keeping use for more than a
single season so it wasn't about the
flavor it was just about the price of
why should the British public out there
be eating more mutton because it's being
extensively grazed it cannot be Factory
farmed it's the wildest and most natural
meat that we can possibly eat and one of
the most
delicious to produce the best mutton
sheep need a diet of good green grass
and correct treatment once they've been
slaughtered a mutton carker should be
hung whole for around about 2 weeks the
meat is extraordinary it's amazing the
difference uh and lamb how dark it is
and it's surrounded by a lot more fat
you can deal with that you know in in
the cooking process you can use the same
Cuts as you do in lamb from mutton and
what's the price of mutton now it's
about half the price of land and twice
as much flavor someone at home cooking
for the first time what would you
recommend oh I'd say I'd say the diced
the diced that would be the one I mean
that's diced up ready now for a stew
ready to go mutton has a reputation for
being slightly tough and the secret
behind this particular dish is the
length of the cooking time so what I'm
cooking here is the simplest of mutton
stew
generous with the seasoning run it
through some flour shake it and into the
pan so what we're doing now is put some
flavor on it
woo once it's brown into the collander
and just leave it to drain vegetables
now this is a stew so we don't have any
little sort of fine dices garlic just in
there in half celery the leaks big of
Rosemary and a nice spring of thyme
pepper corns lightly crush them some out
puree roast it
off half bottle of house red wine take
your mutton mix that in pour boiling hot
water on
top so that's it 2 and 1 half hours on a
low gas
perfect it's
ready now let's see we can convert South
London to
muton you want me to have that tell you
what it's well cooked the m
that is delicious oh it's lovely you
enjoy that m c by you I'd have it any
day am I allow some more promise me
you'll try a mutton stew this
weekend deal deal so come on you not
give mutton a go it is a tasting me and
let's be honest it does deserve a second
chance how's your brownie can I just
tell you what I love come on see that
that's really runny oh yeah that little
chocolate buttons inside love the runny
get off that's
mine can share magic to sh no there's
only one thing that I don't do and
that's share my fings your background in
food you lived in Paris I lived in Paris
and you worked parttime there as a I did
I did I was oh God I was a singing
waitress but can I just say I was a very
good waitress so karaoke was in that
long ago serious that that was good
that's very you ever need I can't
believe you're doing that you're B with
a finger underneath there spoon onto
there I can help Jimmy cars in tonight
yes where is he where oh there he is
there he is there sat upright looking
nice and car now he presented last year
the 100 worth Brits I came 82nd and you
came 95th which is a bit out of now that
you told me that yes I'll me him as well
later as well yeah I'm going to get him
to C yeah big time he actually sits like
a little public school boy over there
doesn't he he's like sort of we're
talking about
[Laughter]
you oh God
and first of all to both of you well
done one step away from working with me
personally Phil how
bad do you want it um the knowledge I'd
learn off you Gordon just be unreal and
it's a Cas if I want to soak up all the
knowledge that you can teach me so I can
take it away and then open my own
restaurant um Russell how bad do you
want it I want it really bad this is
what I'm trying to train for then just
to have that chance and like nothing
like this ever happens to me
and literally being a whole small town
Chinese lad in a takeaway to this what
more can I say it's a tough decision for
me however there's one big difference
between you both this evening because
one of you is a
follower and one of you is a
Creator and
Phil you followed
Russell
and that's the reason why you're going
home tonight I'm really sorry
okay keep going I will do yes yes chef
you cheers thank you very much get some
sleep yeah yeah yeah get your [__]
together yeah thank you Chef
don't welcome to the fword on the menu
tonight for our main course a delicious
pan roasted Seabass with a sweet and
sour pepper
sauce it's gobble gobble croak as the
turkeys breathe their last do I feel any
any rewards do I Janet Street Porter
sets me straight on my fig tart I can
give you my word that any women in the
audience will not eat pastry so you're
wasting your time and my trainees
learned that I won't accept second best
so only going in one play Starling
that's going in the
[Music]
[Applause]
bin love my mother and I love my dad
what have all never had any
my mother and my dad I love my mother
and I love my dad want to have all
never okay on order six covers table two
six RAV main course six C bass Colin
Jackson watch that table please
tonight's starter is a duck and Chestnut
ravoli with a SCE of jusa ma choke how
long
Miller one minute left minut SP then
otherwise I'm going to throw the reing
back let's go yes got this finished I've
got three commies in the kitchen this
week
tamama
Miller and Danny only one of them can
come back next week right now first
table tamama Raves are overcooked
spinach is not ready yes chef how long
for yours 30 seconds let's serve yours
first but can I have the spinach first
Che is ready too late sorry Big Boy
missed your chance that's Cowboy cooking
not in here wakey wakey yes yes chef now
we're serving a derus aloke sauce with
the ravioli don't peel them the flavors
in that skin slice it in half and just
slice it down almost like you're slicing
shalots it's important to start soting
them straight away otherwise they'll go
black now we swe them down we're going
to add some chicken stock but you can
add a vegetable stop stock and keep it
as a vegetarian sauce bring it up to the
boil turn down the heat 8 to 10 minutes
and then they're going to be ready for
puring
look and there we have the most amazing
Dro M choke sauce ready for the ravioli
Miller yes G not too thick and it's like
stge g i Miller you can do something
with these as well now yeah start again
sorry next the filling for the ravioli
duck comy basically it's going to be
cooked in its own fat get your duck fat
and just pour the duck fat over the
legs 180° in the oven for about 1 hour
45 minutes nice and
slow next Shred the duck off the bone
and add a tablespoon each of chestnut
puree Cherry vinegar and double cream
season with chives and bind it all
together get your mix and put it into a
nice ball cuz that's the shape of the
ravioli but look you can still see the
the duck the chives the cream and that's
ready to go in between the pasta two
discs per portion duck into the center
of the pasta and then we use an egg wash
around the outside that binds the pasta
together one disc on top of the other
place over the Rev early push down lift
up into your hands and just squeeze all
the air out and go around and just
remember the sort of days when you used
to grow up with those Flying Saucer
spaceships with a sherbet in the center
that's all we're trying to create nice
round top and a nice round bottom most
important thing about cooking RAV is
always add a touch of oil to the water
that strengthens the pasta when we put
the ravioli in the water and also
protects it then just get the pan and
twist the pan from left to right and
what that does it prevents any ravioli
from sticking on the bottom turn that
gas back up now yeah if you put the six
in there the temperature's gone down so
you have to be intelligent now turn the
heat back up a little bit if it's not
boiling what happens to the ravioli it
will just break apart it burst and it
will sink to the bottom and it'll stick
to the pan then we'll throw more away
and with that you can off home yeah salt
Tam let's go
oh yeah no you just put a big Clump in
there Miller I'll toss it around yeah
yeah or take it out you don't just put a
clump in there otherwise someone's going
to have a very salty ravioli yeah get it
in the bin and start again Chef I've got
10 seconds start yeah that's right I
don't want all that [__] 10 five I
just give you 1 minute yes six RAV in
when they're in the water then you
connect with me until then shut the up
okay they're going in now shf let's go
turn the gas down please
yes okay
spinach the center of the
ball and the spinach helps the ravoli
stay in place now the juice of M choke
sauce that is winter at its best come on
T come on you fast asleep again honestly
you're like a big Telegraph pole come on
big boy you have got to bend those bones
you know that yeah you're about as
flexible as a post box move go Table Six
[Applause]
go how was your dog ravoli it
was this time of year wintry sup Rich
chestnuts beautiful it is so well
balanced the flavors uh very creamy it's
meaty
perfect it's Judgment Day for the
turkeys and it's the first time I've
ever slaughtered an
animal the turkey's time is
[Music]
up hurly witting stall has popped round
to give me some advice on slaughtering
the
turkeys what are your plans for how
they're going to be slaughtered Chris
the farmer is going to come down and and
bring a mobile yeah slaughter house a
trailer and do it properly like yeah
here that's brilliant has he explained
exactly how that's going to be done yeah
it's a very straightforward procedure
they're going to be stung gun they'll
die instantly 3 to 4 seconds that's
definitely the right thing get him here
get it done here and no long Journeys no
extra stress and any preparation for
that I mean absolutely you shouldn't
feed them for 24 hours before Slaughter
really well because you're going to hang
them with the guts in which is right for
developing the flavor but you you want
the guts in but you don't want any [__]
in there it can just maybe turn the
flavor uh a little bit on a long hanging
so now I'm going to starve them for 24
hours before we kill them that's just
the way it goes that's the almost all
animals go to slaughter on an empty
stomach and it's definitely the right
thing for the meat I also asked you
what's the right way to prepare the kids
if as I'm guessing might be likely most
of the kids don't want to see them go to
slaughter no what you should still do I
think is bring them to say goodbye right
so that they understand there's a
finality okay that's it bye-bye to the
we're going to today we're going to say
goodbye to the
turkeys now the morning's arrived for
that
goodbye bit of a milestone today for the
kids I was dying to get to this
particular day because I wanted them to
understand exactly the whole objective
to why we're doing this there we go no h
let them out we say goodbye probably
someone rpy bag which one going to eat
first Nigella G why Nigella because she
the biggest she's the biggest doesn't
mean say she's going to be the tastiest
you know that and but could we keep
their feet no we're not keeping their
feet right listen listen I want you to
say yes goodbye to them we've succeeded
in what we've set out to do Meg growing
our own Christmas lunch well done for
looking after them for me being a chef
of course it's been a you know an
amazing journey for them to understand
what it's like to go to the farm to pick
them up to look after them to feed them
to clean them and then to eat them it's
crucial for any child see bye turkeys in
the oven I'll see you in the
oven can I see them be no you can't see
them being killed
no next on the menu along with our main
course of sea bass with a sweet and sour
pepper
sauce I get Martin McCutchen back in the
kitchen for the perfect roast beef and
yourk pudding thought you'd make me cry
but because you'd be shouting all bit or
something and I get my comist to run the
kitchen on their own the last person on
the hot plate is going home
[Applause]
[__] moment from now yes for SE bass in
let's go Miller yes M yeah Danny yeah
get on the stove I'm hiding yes welcome
back to the f word time now for main
course P roasted Cass with a sweet the
sour pepper
[Music]
[Applause]
sauce seas in French lud that means wolf
of the
sea fill it just run the knife all the
way down one nice long
[Music]
swipe there you go one f it off easy
pepper
sauce rather than cut the peppers in
half and take out the seeds just cut
around it leave the seeds in there and
do the job
once it's almost likely if you're
peeling an
orange
shots nice hot pan Olive
Oil star Ines the an flavor goes
absolutely beautifully with the
sweetness of the peppers
salt
Basel white wine
vinegar
Burma reduce it gives body to the sauce
nice glossy
syrupy 200 M of
water simmer it's fresh it's vibrant and
it goes brilliantly with a sea
bass
Blitz
absolutely beautiful bass
score
salt thyme it just so perfumes the sea
bass olive oil skin side
down in it goes fingers on top for 30
seconds 90% of the cooking time will
take place in that skin but you'll know
when it's cooked when it starts turning
bright white now it's time to turn it
over just finish it with olive oil seab
Bass with pepper sauce
done with the sea bass we're serving
brazed on and rice
peaf now oniv is something you eat a lot
of raw in salads like quite like it this
way because it's sort of roasted brazed
cooked in orange juice and it's the
perfect way of cooking on especially in
Winter now that we' got the color on
there the caramelization is taking place
on the outside it's time to add a touch
of Gram on you grum on your
Ino Merry
Christmas once we've burnt off the
alcohol get your orange
juice give it a good Shake and now look
orange juice into the
pan into the
oven 10 to 12 minutes and by the time
the orange juice is evaporated the Onie
is
cooked Miller yes
G look at the bass Miller it's only
going in one plague Starling that's
going in the bin it's burnt start again
yes
no and Danny what the are you
doing what are you doing I was just
making sure this didn't burn chef and
you're making sure the SE is burned
you've done that already no the the
sauce Chef I just took it off theat
right okay basically can you get a grip
yes Che temp portion SE pass in the bin
nothing happening yes you're looking
busy we're actually doing nothing and
all you're doing just spinning around
yeah like this bobbing around nothing's
actually been done now there's the top
of the Onie yeah get the Onie coming
back down like this is that a nice
little point it had and place the base
of the Onie
yeah at the base of the plate look yeah
and follow up now watch there's the SE
bus there's the top there's the bottom
wipe the Cass on there now look I'm
going to show this one watch sauce one
spoon round and look at the colors look
there you go well done finish it off H
long Miller please now look at that
there look yeah beautiful the colors are
there yes do that plate I'll do this
one yes happy with that where you sure
are you happy with that wa so you should
be go
[Music]
please I've been in another woman's
kitchen this week helping her to make
the perfect roast beef and Yorkshire
[Music]
pudding change my mind
see you hold on AE we're going to have
perfect Sunday dinner roast beef roast
potatoes yure puddings some carrots and
cabbage and then maybe a really nice
sort of um sexy gravy can I just say in
advance that I'm quite an intelligent
woman but when it comes to the kitchen I
don't mind admitting I a complete bimbo
what's that um uh some Holland Daisy Sal
sauce Holland Daisy salty sauce no
that's dripping that's going to make the
perfect perfect pudding so the key to
this is to have a Time plan right yeah
everything else after that falls into
sink there's a cloth for you so always
keep your cloth there like that so
you've always got it to hand up and down
not over the shoulder not left lying
around and then when you want to touch
something in the oven you can always
just hold it there nip it out first
thing most important thing we'll get the
beef in now season the fat season the
fat yeah cuz what that does gets rid of
the water in the fat and makes it a lot
more tasty start off on 250° 250 there
we go there's the first L put in the OV
so the first time we stuck one in the
oven yeah um York pudding mix one two
and then finger and thumb in and just
lift open one egg okay you've got a bit
of shell in there where there you
[Laughter]
s yeah yeah yeah my nerves are
gone okay well he is human I'm going get
some milk bitter pepper oh my so it's
fat so that's going to help them rise
and stop them from sticking do we have
to add that much in there you putting my
milk in there yeah just a tablespoon
just heart attack put that in there over
we go to the tray in one that's it good
a little bit more good whil the beef is
roasting away they should go zoom and
now we just do the easy stuff roast
potatoes I have had nights where I'm
thinking God it would be so great if I
could cook right now Christmas dinner
sometimes I'd like Christmas at mine and
then my mom's like no why do we have it
at yours because then we've got to cook
and we haven't got everything we need
there and we have to bring everything
with us I like to get the tray on top of
the gas ring before it goes in the oven
it just stops it from sticking watch
your fingers Ros keeps bloody spitting
yeah it does spit that's the water from
the potatoes now you can start to see
the potatoes coloring a little bit let's
check the beef put your fingers like
this and just touch your jaw like that
inside of your cheek yeah mine's very
squidy yeah that means it's rare when
you hit on the beef like that so that's
still quite rare if it's medium it's
firm it's like your chin medium well
done well done they are absolutely
amazing just to finish them off properly
the secret is to turn them around turn
them upside down so they cook underneath
oh look at that I'm going throw in a
little bit of
onion do you know what they're doing my
eyes in yeah absolutely
right there I dear
cool [__] they're strong I thought you'd
make me cry but because you'd be
shouting all it or something not because
of the onions what are we doing now
gravy
gravy what I'm going to do is just put
some of these tomatoes in the bottom all
they're going to do is actually make the
gravy a little bit sweet yeah I grew up
in a three-bedroom Council estate shared
a bedroom my brother this kind of food
we didn't eat no I didn't either there's
quite a few foods that I was kind of
quite frightened of I must admit like
what well I mean the word organic I
immediately thought that that was
something disgusting for a long time
when I was when I was younger uhhuh and
when people used to say that they were
kind of vegetarian I us to think what's
that what on Earth would you eat then
cuz everything like I say was chicken
chips and beans fish chips and beans
yeah you know and that was it and that
was it nice little butter in there
where's the butter butter should be in
the fridge okay how big do you want the
knob to
be pass that through a Sie right so have
I got time to quickly just put a bit of
makeup on and brush my hair and make it
look like this was completely effortless
yep great um how long 5 minutes of
course it's natural yeah
now women back in the
[Music]
kitchen
W coming girls you're
right I know right they're here they're
here and I've set them down I love my
friends but they are quite judgmental
are they when it comes to my cooking
I've never seen her in the kitchen
actually fussy um they're just they're
just dreading it I think Martin cooking
are we a bit worried don't worry about
getting everything sort of piping hot
the Beast rested York qus are served at
room temperature yeah and are you sure
they meant to be served at room
temperature no what we'll do just before
take the potatoes out we'll stick them
in the oven littleit absolutely definite
try and keep the plates nice and clean
so it looks like I really do know what
I'm doing yeah and you're in control
that beef looks delicious yeah see how
it's coming together col it's just all
almost coming out like a sort of a chain
reaction this has to be your Pier the
resistance on show crispy a nice and
line look at that yeah that's it good
ready well that's it well done babe now
yeah here we go
okay thank you Bab that is probably one
of the best y puddings I've ever toasted
in my
life I can't stop thinking about that
you've done it
that's what's going through every
mouthful I'm just thinking God
Martin cheers everybody well done well
done cheers my request that you don't
let off the
hook thank you thank you right Danny
Miller Tama come here yes now the
Brigade are going out and you're going
to cook a table on your own yes yes chef
okay the last person on the hot plate is
going home Che Miller you got four SE
bass table 12 wait Danny you got six se
bass table eight and you T got five SE
bass table five yes whoever doesn't do
it up to scratch okay is going home 4
minutes on the hot plate move your ass
yes P piping hot sauce beautifully
seasoned Seabass nice and crispy
seasoned with th flowers rock salt in
there yes let's go come on Tama watch
your bass don't blow it now big boy yeah
let's go yes
good pull the pan
down not enough color on there Danny so
I don't know why you turning them look
that looks boiled we might as well steam
the seab bass jef I'm ready in 1 minute
minute I'll be very surprised if those
seed basss are ready in 1
minute how long Danny Make It Count yes
three 3 minutes Che service please t
five here
don't SL the plates up now take your
time yes come on we all started off at
the same time however it's all coming
out in different times quite interesting
let's go don't you dare send
that come on hurry up work and talk the
same time stop gping oh all that lovely
delicious food now you're going to send
on dirty plates you ready yes sure send
it then okay can you go please table
five five we listening interesting right
down the hot plate how long m please I'm
coming up now you're coming up now yes
table 12 melow please table 12 how long
Danny 1 minute
Chef nicely
Sauced very nicely saued bass
Che now that's one piece of bass yes
yeah and the person sat opposite we sat
with that piece of
bass different size and and they went in
the pan at the same time so they won't
be cooked the same are you happy with
that that's the question I've got to ask
you no Chef now no I respect you
honestly thank
you cuz I'm not happy with
that four more B start again service oh
no I'm going
home that's the top of the bass that's
the belly turn it around yeah I mean
I've been meaning for the last 4 hours
that's better thank you okay table 16 go
thank you can't dny please it's how long
it's not quite there Chef one fish not
quite there you're okay not quite long
I've got to have a one minute one minute
there you go thank you
yes t 10 please
mhm ladies Gordon that how was The
bestass Gorge I like it yes was that
wild or farmed that we don't use Farm
line C right and cooked on the skin so
nice and crispy I the skin I think the
skin people I it really annoys me when I
see people leave the skin because the
skin is where all the nutrition is
that's where all the oil is that's why
we cook it on that and of course we
season it with time flowers and it's
really nice and crispy it was really
really good I'm not a massive fish fan
but I think this has converted me there
was a lot of depth to the flavors I
think um terrifically Tangy um red
pepper sauce fantastic really you really
enjoyed it love it okay uh Tama yeah
Danny I'm M quick yes sorry well done
yeah that was a test of push you to the
extreme there you know that yeah and boy
did it feel like you're really on your
own there cooking everything from the on
peel out the bass that was the race to
see who had it together do you
understand yes and Danny I so respect
what you said there because you knew one
bass was overcooked and one bath was
cooked perfectly yes unfortunately not
good enough
yeah but you got to be happy with
yourself tomorrow morning yeah the
effort big boy was 110% and something to
be really proud of good night good
remember what you did guys yes say good
night to
him next on the menu it's pudding time
Janet Street Porter thinks her baked fig
recipe is better than mine i' like to
wish you good luck yes you wishing me Lu
I it with your track record I should be
wishing you luck and jles Corin finds
out what your pet restaurant hates so if
our M John Baptist came over to you in
the restaurant in the f word restaurant
and said excuse done we have another tit
in here uh what would you do I think I
compl complain
actually and It's the final countdown
for the turkeys I'm going to put that in
its mouth and then
[Applause]
the now it's time for pudding and Janet
Street por is going to attempt to beat
me with her favorite fig pudding I
always said that to my sort of fellow
contestants good luck you're wishing me
luck I think with your track record I
should be wishing you luck I can tell
you got attitude already your hands are
folded are you my body language is like
body language I know this kind of
dessert is a bit beneath you it's not
complicated enough for you is it yeah
not unless you're going to make some
chocolate doodly Dar thing on the top
just going to be a nice simple thig tart
nothing tart you're making a tart you
were in the kitchen so I thought nothing
better to do than a nice Tas you're
making a fit T yes you absolute slimy
just going baked figs what do you mean
since when did you add the pastry bit I
thought we were cooking the same thing
it's a fig recipe you had your baked I
can give you my word that any women in
the audience will not eat pastry so
you're wasting your time I'm making the
kind of dessert women like every fruit
we'll find not pastry fruit right okay
I'm not going to argue not now we've
only we've been in the kitchen 3 minutes
go D this is a bit of a very easy
dessert which is B figs which you just
cut up and
then you squeeze so they open up a bit
and also when you buy the figs you don't
want to be buying figs that are too rip
because they'll disintegrate before you
even start fck her off no don't put me
off shut up just move away I'm just
sprinkling over some brown sugar Jan is
doing a baited fig um dessert I'm doing
a very very simple straightforward fig
tart which Janet thinks is slightly Pony
but it's not it's just puff pastry
frangie pan which is made out of almonds
egg sugar and icing sugar we're going to
spread the frangie pan on the puffed
pastry and just bake it in the oven for
2 to 3 minutes and then once the frangie
pan starts to cook I'm going to take out
the tart and lay the figs on there in
the oven 2 and 1 half 3 minutes done in
we go just adding some marala which is a
sweet Italian uh dessert wine you can
use it it's worth having a bottle of
this at home actually because you you
can use it in uh quite a lot of desserts
good for tri
for now I know you're trying to put me
off but look what's happening now to my
fig tart p is half cooked franie pan
started to rise all I'm going to do now
is just put the figs on top that doesn't
look Pony to you does it and look what
I'm doing IC and sugar yeah and five
spice okay lays over the tart oh I'm so
determined I'm going to win this one you
know that do have a little smell of that
it smells fantastic it's great now we're
going to glaze them in the oven how are
yours doing they're fine they need a bit
longer now it's quite fascinating you
are a classified foodie but was it your
mom who taught you or oh my mother
couldn't cook my mother was a ghastly
cook she could only cook I wish she
belongs to that generation where they
cooked everything for far far too
long Sunday lunch I mean they literally
put the meat on the minute you finished
breakfast and then there's that strange
working class meal called tea which you
have on a Sunday where you open a tin of
ham and you have the salad which is is a
lettuce with two tomato can I look at my
fig yes of course you
can yeah they're done they're done how'd
you know they're done cuz they're sof to
the T yes um are you cooking this for
your birthday and we're not allowed to
say it's your 59th birthday are we say
I'm 59 and you can say I'm nearly as old
as your mother you're rude you are the
same age as my mom I look great so I
know you do now do you know what I'm
going to do now just while they're
coming out of the oven still nice and
warm just going to glaze it with a
little bit of honey heat it up and then
back in the oven for 30 seconds now do
you cook at home with your partner we
don't cook at the same time why I've
been married four times Gordon I know
where it all goes wrong so I don't want
it to go wrong so we never cook the same
meal at the same time so that's where it
goes he he wants to eat things like
mashed potato I can't eat mashed potato
I'll have an as the size of a house
honey figs spice have you any idea how
much I got to win this hey you got no
idea you like to do an entirely
different dish to me in order to
win hey hey that's that's hot in there a
little bit of a rest time yeah slightly
sort of come down time yes how was you
see bass it was lovely flavors are just
not too overpowered no no CH yeah CH
nice you do quite a lot of cooking I do
I do I enjoy cooking it's one of the the
only few creative things I say I can do
and how did you learn to mean who how
did you first get involved with sort of
cooking
no I used to watch just sit and watch
didn't do anything take any lessons do
any recipe books just watch how my
parents used to cook and my father used
to do most of the cooking my very first
meal I ever cooked wasn't a Jamaican
meal fan you know no it was sweet and
sour pork sweetness out and I was nine I
did that you guys have been spending a
lot of time together over the last
couple of months yes was there in a good
teacher was she excellent patience of a
saint show me position one there's no
position we don't have that is there ask
him to show you a um um a chaar or show
me position it's quite difficult I mean
the first thing if you you try to learn
to certainly when we're doing some of
the S is to try to learn to roll your
hips over roll and back slowly do
slowly you've been doing this for two
months now so do slowly make sure no
one's watching yeah you take your foot
to the side you roll in through you H
and go back
[Applause]
hey done that no no that looks the bces
of a good Latin dancer it's looking
good hold on guys thank you
cheers hello chares hello Gordon what
you been doing this week I've been I've
been looking at things that ought to be
banned from restaurants you know
basically the government are Banning
smoking yes from everywhere and I
thought smoking I I know they're B it's
bned in your but it's not the end of the
world smoking and there are things which
are far more irritating in in restaurant
so we did a we did a survey to find out
what what other things people would like
to see
bandn welcome to Shay jiley for one day
only the owners of this restaurant have
kindly L it to me and now that I'm a
restaurer I'm going to start Banning
things almost everything the things that
annoy me I don't know what annoys you
for example people who drink cappuccinos
after dinner it's a breakfast drink or
ugly people they just put me off my food
supposing it was your restaurant though
what would you ban the Harden's
restaurant guide has concluded that
people who eat out regularly find one in
four meals unsatisfactory in a bit to
try and improve things we commissioned a
survey of 2,000 people to find out what
the public would like to see banned from
restaurants forever I hate that having
to buy a bottle of water when a glass of
t water would do 10th most popular
answer was paying for bottle Still Water
nonetheless this year restaurants have
shifted 200 million bottles of it bad
background music music needs to be
banned M background music is there at
number nine women wiing really chokingly
over AAR in perfume in our survey that
was the eighth most popular
answer can you think of anything else
that people might like to see banned
from restaurants I think probably
children do you think we should ban
children you think we should just throw
them out or do you think we should let
them stay let them stay absolutely
unfortunately Banning children came in
at number
seven breastfeeding I think if women
want to breastfeed then they should be
encouraged to do it in the
window six in our top 10 of most popular
answers was breastfeeding in
restaurants but 2third of mothers
attempt to breastfeed their babies and
the wind is definitely behind
breastfeeders in Scotland now you're
committing a crime if you try to stop it
and UNICEF wants the rest of the UK to
go the same way if if people are that
offended it's up to them to leave it's
not not up to me if my child's hungry
and wants to eat then you know to me
it's more embarrassing and it would
disturb ruin your evening more to have a
baby that was screaming so if our mat D
John Baptist came over to in the
restaurant in the f word restaurant and
said there we have no here uh what would
you do I think I think I probably
complain
actually what do you think the most
popular answer might have been maybe
pda's kissing making public displays of
affection fifth in the survey was
snugging in restaurants with more than a
quarter of people voting for it to be
banned toilets are not the sort of place
you'd want to be parked close by so bad
placement of tables our survey says that
tables too close to the L are at number
four mobile phones people talking on
their mobile phones one minute one
minute uh yeah no I'm I'm doing doing a
bit of Telly sorry what was that you
were saying there was something you want
mobile phones oh unsurprisingly mobile
phones come in nice and high at number
three but women are less interested in
Banning them than
men what do you think the top answer
might have been say if you're going for
a romantic meal and you get play like
sat next to um a whole group full of
people maybe that haven't seen each
other for ages so what you we're
basically talking about is badly planned
tables specifically thinking about
romantic couples yeah yeah tables too
close together it's our second most
popular answer one of the most
irritating is when uh you are charged
service charge and then of course you
get you know the chit back after they've
taken your card away and on it will be
gratuity as well so that thing where
they actually add the
122% and then they bring it back nice
little you know space gratuity and you
think well you know I've paid that much
so should I actually doubly pay it's our
top answer the terrible practice of
trying to make people tip twice is what
most people want
banned and you're not the only ones the
trading standards people are unhappy
about it too we looked at about 95
restaurants across London and found out
that um well over half of them were were
practicing double tipping so what
couldn't be done about this we forwarded
our findings to the Department of trade
and Industry um as far as I'm aware they
haven't done anything about it to date
double tipping you voted it the thing
you most want to see banned from British
restaurants but this lot clearly are not
going to do anything about it so we're
going to have to and our campaign begins
with you what you have to do is log on
to the fword website and name and shame
any restaurant that has ever tried it on
with you you've cooked the Nonet option
and I've cooked the option for women who
do not want to have big bums oh come
on oh I just I want to taste my juice I
want to taste my
juice that is fantastic stop it stop it
oh God do you want to taste my juice
tastes a little bit like Benin right
John Baptist Benin up you go yes cough
mixture nice and soft with a pastry
delicious it's delicious but it's too
rich for me oh here we go
it smells lovely a bit hard is it felo
pastry well either that or puff pastry
that shouldn't rise BL
me it's caramel it looks yeah it looks
like it's been caramelized it's hot
they're not too sweet aren they okay so
now we serving dessert number two
okay the figs are figs are kind of
juicier and plumper aren't they I love
the um the juice around it the sauce
around
it thank you okay uh Johan Baptist you
will the winner
is
Janet
fantastic
fantastic are you sure yes yes I say but
what did they say you shouldn't take me
off you shouldn't have took my I told
you I already F the the puff pastry a
little bit too hard the puff pastry a
little bit too ice cream you know with
the reason in the vanill do you know my
Saving Grace I'm actually quite happy
it's to lose to a talented cook D get
out Janet Street Porter
confident next week on the F-word we
finally get to eat the turkeys but first
I have to kill them I don't want them to
have to travel before Slaughter so I'm
going to do it in my
garden turkey farmer Chris Frederick has
returned to my house with a mobile
Slaughter
unit I'm going to take them put them in
the shackle here and then I am going to
stun them this is the probe I'm going to
put that in its mouth yeah I just hit
the button and
the for God's
sake oh mate look at you sat on your
perch relax relax do I feel any remorse
do I feel slightly
guilty do
I I'm not going to have a go at
slaughtering myself Chris is a licensed
Slaughter man so my turkeys are in
expert
hands one two two
three irids are coming back we're about
there that was so quick that's it done
just cutting the arteries and rains in
the back of the throat
they no obvious discomfort the bir at
all can I just say thank God the girls
aren't here you know that the bag on
this head is full just for our
convenience we so we're not splashing
blood around over place okay so we're
going to go on with the plucking now the
turkeys are staying in their houses so
they can't see what's going on Angley
Ready Steady pluck
yeah easely okay here we
go oh
Gaza let's go big
boy there you go
excellent okay that'll
do Annie Parker works at Chris's farm
and has been plucking since she was six
um it's the first time I plucked a
turkey was quite scary really yeah and
how many birds can you pluck in one day
probably about 30 30 your hands must
they must hurt no towards the end of the
day yeah get a bit sore on your fingers
and it's a lot easier to do it when
they're warm yeah much easier yeah it's
starting off with cold hands can be a
bit slow working on the farm you don't
get attached them do you oh no no
definitely
not what would you give me as a piece of
advice to always start from the wings
always on the wings cuz they're the
thinnest part of the bird that's right
yeah work your way down to the neck yeah
and then just come back up to the breast
and just work your way around so you get
to the ls and don't rip them so when you
first met your boyfriend yeah what did
you do oh I'm a mechanic oh what do you
do love yeah I'm a turkey
plucker this one's cleaned up very very
well has isn't he one pluck
Gary Come on Jamie be a good boy here we
go straight into the shackle yeah we got
I'm standing well back there's 600 volts
going through those birds let's go
deia co
dear
stunned come on
Nigel God she's so big she can't even
fit through the door the last one why do
we use electricity and not breaking the
neck well we find it much more humane
way of dealing with the job very quick
and um straightforward that's the job
done for the day it's a sad ending but
it's the start of an exciting beginning
okay oh dear finally that's exactly what
I've
wanted stun guned plucked and ready for
The Butchers thank God the kids aren't
[Applause]
here enjoying the taste of Victory Madam
I am mad I bet you are they sliding down
the back of the throat with the greatest
of ease yeah it's good it's it it does
taste nice yes I'm glad you're happy I
do I loved it good girl you know Jen's
being p as happy everybody won't
laugh hi R hello how are you Dy very
well did you enjoy your figs I thought
they were okay okay nothing more nothing
special I'm so what you've been up to
this week I've been looking at labels
and what they do and don't tell you
about products especially when they
suggest something good for
you most of us would like to be healthy
and eat foods that are good for us so
when we shop we pick up things that fit
in with that but because of our current
labeling laws manufacturers can
perfectly legally present Foods in a way
that suggests they might be better for
us than they really are take this for
example it's an officially lowfat
biscuit personally I'd imagine that if I
bought this I'd be eating less calories
but what the front of the packet doesn't
tell you is that these biscuits are very
high in sugar so these officially lowfat
biscuits contain more calories than
these and these and these none of which
I'd dream of buying if I was watching my
[Music]
weight is it just me or are other people
confused by the labels on the front of
products why would you buy something
that said low fat on it cuz it makes you
feel better about what you're eating
really do you think it might be low
calorie well if it's saying low fat one
would assume I suppose that the two are
linked you expect them to tell you the
truth
not just skip over the bad bit they
shouldn't be allowed to have that in big
letters and what really is content in
small letters the labels on many
products make claims about their fat
content but the front of the packet only
tells half the story when manufacturers
reduce the fat often you lose flavor and
they may add sugar in order to give you
back that flavor but the claim that
they're making is only about that
specific nutrient if it's low in fat
that's all they're claiming what's
really important is that you look at the
whole food look at the back of the pack
and I think manufacturers could make
that labeling much clearer it's amazing
what the labeling laws allow look at
this this is a plain yogurt with 3.7 G
of fat per 100 G and this is a lowf fat
yogurt with 1.2 gram of fat per 100 gram
I can add this whole bag of sugar and
this still counts as a low fat yogurt
which is a claim that the other one just
can't make y well officially that is
still less than 3% fat so that is a
lowfat food but if I were to have just
three dessert spoons of that yogurt I'd
be having the same number of calories as
this chocolate bar so we know what's in
here but if we tell the public it's low
fat I wonder which one they'll choose we
go for the low fat one low fat yogurt
you put a whole bag of sugar in and I
and and the law allows me to say lowfat
yogurt but I don't have to say plus a
bag of sugar that's you look quite
surprised yeah I am quite surprised yeah
yeah I would say that was
wrong I'm hoping that witch can explain
the situation to me the law on health
and nutrition claims just isn't Tough
Enough while it is against the law for
manufacturers to deliberately mislead in
terms of the claims they make there are
a number of confusing and contradictory
health and nutrition claims out there on
the market it's not just low fat
guidelines on words like light or l i t
are so vague manufacturers can use them
to imply a food is better for us than
similar products even if they still
contain what's been defined as a lot of
fat or sugar so what's being done about
all of this well proposals are being
discussed here from January next year in
the European Parliament that will
address all these issues that will give
clear definitions and make sure claims
are checked we're calling on UK MEPS and
the British government to support these
proposals to make sure that consumers
can make a properly informed choice so
next time you go shopping remember
remember check the back of the packet as
well as the front look at all the
nutritional information and if you'd
like to see the law changed and the
regulations tightened visit the fword
website and find out how you can make it
happen Tama Miller let's
go and first of all to both of you well
done thank thank you tough day if you
were my shoes Tama okay and you had to
send one of you guys home who would it
be and why um so far from day one coming
here I've learned and I I know I've got
so much more to go you know such a big
journey ahead of me but I'm hoping that
you know you'll take me back next week
so I can learn a little bit more with
you and um
Miller I hope you'd send emmer home um I
think you'll admit there's a difference
from how I was in the beginning um and I
I think it can only get better um I
think I can bring commitment and
maturity and just just really hard work
frankly to the
kitchen and I want to do that you both
did exceptionally
well the person who's going to be going
home is
Tama let me just say this you're 18
years of
age even in my kitchens I don't have
many 18-year-old Cooks as strong as you
thank you you did very
well thanks congratulations thank you
very much I'll see you next week yeah I
think he deserves a kiss well done you
welcome to the fword tonight I have to
win the dessert challenge I'm going head
to-head with him H early wiing School
unfortunately there's a new judge in the
house I'm going to be firm but
fair it's Christmas in the fword
restaurant and my menu wouldn't be
complete without deia anley Jamie
Anthony Nigella and
Gary I get banged up for
Christmas [__] [__]
H and the pressure's on for Russell and
Miller by the end of tonight one of
these two will be coming to work for me
if I had to make the decision on those
last two tables there Russell you'd be
going home the was here and the was B my
mother and I C my dad I love mother and
I love my dad all never had any here the
CR my mother and CR my dad and I love my
mother and I love my dad want to have
all
[Music]
never ready on order four cover 10 four
soup main course four turkey yes one no
breadcrumbs watch out table yes Russell
and Miller are the two comies in the
kitchen this evening by the end of
tonight one is going to win a job in one
of my restaurants and the other one's
going home sorry Gordon [__] you're
nearly going
home watch the tickets Please R I'm
trying to run a [__] hot plate here
and you're knocking them all over the
place yeah come on yeah you're like a
baby [__] rhinoceros come
on Russell move your ass Table Six yes
four oyer soup yeah try and serve it
before [__] midnight now tonight's
starter is oyers in Champagne with a
cucumber papadeli don't turn your nose
about oysters they are delicious and a
real Gourmet treat if you don't like raw
oysters try cooking them because they
taste amazing and can be enjoyed by the
most squeamish guess now first of all
got to open the oyster don't be scared
of doing this because it's actually
quite straightforward all we have to do
is get the knife and Pierce inside the
muscle not at the side not at the end
cuz that's where the Shell's really
brittle just push down on top of the
oyster until you get through and then
just twist and the shell just pops
off open
up just cut through the muscle and out
into the bowl
these are rock oysters and they're from
Devon and they're one of the tastiest
you can get this time of
year right cucumber not too much
cucumber yes all we do is get the peeler
place the Cucumber down and peel these
really nice strips of
cucumber and they not only look
fantastic but it means they actually
sort of look identical to papadeli pasta
and they take seconds to
cook bring to the the boil a couple of
ladles of vegetable stock add the
Cucumber oyster juice and the cream
bring back to the boil and add your
oysters you've really got to move your
ass because the oysters is overcook
within seconds so youve really got to be
quick and 30 seconds off the
Heat next add a pinch of salt and a
sprinkling of fresh chives and then
we're going to finish the soup with
champagne the only thing is missing now
the touch of lettuce and that literally
goes in seconds before you serve it
take your
cucumber and that is a fantastically
light tasty Sumptuous beautiful soup
that's been finished with champagne and
lettuce service please T 7 Jean Baptist
Ali go use a ladle please we're going to
be all night at Russell I said a l i
can't keep on telling you again yes
there's no lettuce in there
oh come on excuse me get me the soup
back from the table Gord is very happy
we Sorry H up pleas you find it's funny
you're laughing away I want the [__]
suit back just get the [__] bowl from
the table let's go two more pans what
happened there Miller half the table had
lettuce the other table didn't get a pan
please back up to the boil quickly and
the oysters are overcooked Miller start
again hurry
up hello ladies you got the best table
in the house three ladies all to
yourself I'm lucky man do you enjoy your
oysters it was very good first time as
well oh really anything happening
downstairs not quite yet I'll let you
lat a mighty should have happen half an
hour ago any help huh dear
dear how are you Dy M good to see you
thank you Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas welcome welcome welcome now
Christmas in the Osborn household yes
that must be mad no it's really you know
hustle bustle hectic dogs kids a whole
lot I imagine Aussie biting the head off
a turkey before it goes in the other no
he ends up cooking it I he does he ends
up cooking cuz I can't I can't believe
that he does the [__] cooking in your
house what's he like what kind of things
does he cook Good Old English thick
chips he does and they're brilliant
ready do you get excited about going out
to dinner with good food I do I really I
you know there's such a difference
between good food and food yeah now it's
been well documented your relationship
with food Bia for instance it's a thing
of when we all need to eat and I would
need to eat but I would hate the fact
that I needed to eat so I'd want to get
rid of it and then I I just wouldn't
feel clean I had to just get it out of
my body cuz it was crap that I was
eating I mean that's all under control
now that's been yeah yeah yeah it is
extraordinary the fact that you look
amazing how did you keep it up and what
was the last thing you had done oh
cosmetic yes my boobs your boobs yeah
but I don't like them now they're too
big so I'm going to have to change does
Aussie think they're too big no he likes
them but they're amazing you don't need
to change them no they're too big they
weigh a honestly they do they weigh a
lot and it's like N Ready yeah have we
ever had oysters before I haven't cuz I
think they look like Bogies big
Bogies Jean Baptist play
oh did you hear that that accent now I I
don't think you're going to chew Sharon
being Sharon you're going to swallow
ready babe just have a little smell
smells like an old Fanny this is a high
quality oyster you can
absolutely can't believe you just said
that about my oyster you I'll take this
big one ready so up til down finger
go all right let's smell your breath
now
and the low fat as well this one that's
a little bit smaller this one you
okay maybe turn around the other way
because that see that's it's like a a
pearl that there is to sort of fit onto
your mouth okay can't wait it feels like
a
testicle all right come on babe straight
down well
done un
swallow
no what was that like it's like being
and bleeding brighten and taking get a
mouthful of sea water damn you didn't
like that no that's supposed to be an
aphrodisiac he's Aussie in for a good
night not with this breath he's not
it'll murder
him next on the menu the kids get to eat
anony and if things go wrong I'll be
stuck with a family of vegetarians bye
Anthony bye watch out go I'm off to
harate in North Yorkshire to get a
vica's wife back in the kitchen the
freezer is Central to my cooking give us
this day our daily bread and I leave the
commies in charge of the kitchen so it
could be me that ends up stuffed is it
[__] warm no no so you want to serve
that no now get the Sprouts off and get
them in the [__] Pat let's
[Applause]
go Russell you're sending table 16 16
Mill you're sending table three table
three welcome back to the fword now next
up the main course homegrown roasted
turkey turkey the one hit one Wonder um
absolutely amazing bird stuff onion
orange garlic thy and
Bailey
season truffle butter this little beauty
helps to take the turkey to a different
division these cost 50 Quid for that
size yes it's expensive but boy is it
worth
[Music]
it don't chop the Truffle too small
because we want to taste and identify
the
Truffle
parsley
Tagan salt Touch of
pepper tablespoon of olive oil and that
stops the butter from
burning take your Piping Bag and fill
it separate skin from
meat pip bag in PIP
butter
massage salt
pepper olive oil
roast Citrus
breadcrumbs
[Applause]
Panetta
onion time you don't need to good old
Chef's trick and pull down and just peel
it of his lovely
flowers pine nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
butter
bread
orange
[Music]
lemon and as it start Browning sprinkle
your orange and lemon
breadcrumbs lemon
juice there we go
beautiful rest Temple keeps it nice and
warm when it cools down slowly so the
breast become really nice and moist calm
what you can smell of course is that
amazing
truffle absolutely
beautiful turkey with truffle butter and
citrus breadcrumbs
done now let me show you something quick
come here Anthony nigell and deal are
all in the oven have a quick look don't
touch there there you go that's Anthony
in there for the past 3 months my kids
Megan Holly Jack and Matilda have been
rearing their own turkeys for Christmas
tonight they'll finally get to eat them
wave goodbye Anthony quick you're in
there bye Anthony bye right watch out go
right at the table up at the table SC to
see he's gone he's going in the oven
come on at the table Matilda dear
dear [__] hell now four minutes on
the hot plate yes so move your ass yeah
a little bit of energy yes in fact lots
of energy yes and yes it is a race
Miller let's go D now with the turkey
we're serving roast potatoes carrots and
brussel sprouts brussels sprouts always
get a hard time and when only get to eat
them once a year however do not put a
cross at the bottom like my mom does
when you crisscross the bottom of that
you end up with them soggy overcooked
Sprout leave them whole into the boiling
water and cook for 3 and 1/ half to 4
minutes then take them out and dump them
straight in ice water so it stops them
from ever cooking then we're going to so
them very very quickly with some almonds
so the Sprouts just start to color and
the almonds just start going that really
nice nut brown Flavor now the roast
potatoes that going with a turkey are
Charlottes they're small rich and very
waxy so you don't need to part boil them
before you roast them and this way the
flavor is extraordinary into the pan
season and color on the stove in Goose
or duck
fat and if you give the potatoes color
before they get in the oven you get this
really nice crispy flavor around the
outside come on come on come on really
important now the fingers are moving
fast yes come here you don't serve it
are you happy with that yeah reasonably
you are yes you haven't even tested it
to see it is warm yeah should still warm
cuz this bit's warm as well yeah touch
that there come on Russell yeah that's
not quite warm is it [__] warm no it's
not no so you want to serve that no Che
no get the Sprouts off and get them in
the [__] pan let's go y so delicious
turkey nice hot potatoes yeah roasted
carrots and [__] Stone Cold Russel
sprouts come
on right Russell come here Miller come
here that wasn't good
enough little bit all over the shop you
know that you Stone Cold vegetables your
turkey carving is shocking how can you
call that carved it's like you've been
in there with a [__] shovel if I had
to make the decision on those last two
tables there Russell you'd be going
home pull it back the chef one table of
five each let's go
again how about getting the turkey
sliced on the tray this time yeah
getting your vegetables piping hot and
plating your turkey and your veg at the
same time yes Here We Go Make It Count
move your ass
yes
clean your [__] place come
on nice portions piping hot
veg let's go good well done Big Boy Yes
you saved your skin there big boy go
table 12 nice go
please come on M yes go 12 please
go
[Music]
[Applause]
right I'm going to nip in there how was
Nigella breast moist I have to say you
you've pulled off the hardest thing in
turkey cooking really which is moist
breast with I'm a turkey skeptic as I
know you are you're a plucking INF
finicki turkey grower I yes and I and
I'm fussy about turkey and very very
rarely is it cooked properly and that's
really hard to pull off coming from youu
I'm honored thank you no it was really
really good how do you feel about
Nigella being a
man
confused nigela a man cared for by Jack
age five I mean there's a Providence I
mean I like menus where they talk about
the Providence of the meat you know
traceability yeah traceability now I'll
see you later for dessert yes I'll see
you for the pudding ch how you feeling
about that I'm slightly nervous huh good
to see
you turkey is lovely and moist there's a
lot of lemon in it sometimes I'm not
sure about lemon you know so much lemon
but I did enjoy it and I thought that
the actual texture of the meat is lovely
and the Sprouts are just the kind of el
Dente that I struggle to get she said
you're the little dog he good to see you
you know is different about your sprouts
and my Sprouts a hard not C excuse me
excuse me hold on hold on hold on hold
Ste don't you start ganging up on me
there was no crisscrosses on my Sprouts
that's why they so they weren't soggy
mom now we Ser them whole for once they
were hard you don't remember every time
Mom served Crown she served them by the
leaves see you shortly
yes given it Christmas I thought I'd get
a vica's wife back in the kitchen and
believe me she needed a
miracle Christmas for a viage family I
would say it's wall to--all Church Mark
does all the cooking except at Christmas
when it does fall to me I don't think
I've ever really learned to cook give us
this day our daily bread the freezer is
Central to my cooking and forgive us our
trespasses as we forgive them that
trespass against us an alternative
Christmas lunch would be would be
interesting areen the ideal Christmas
meal for me would be something that
could be prepared in advance that was
easily cooked and served but that also
was exciting and that I had done for
myself and I would really love to see
the family's face when I put that down
hi Ruth hi Gordon how are you right how
are you I feel like Santa Claus great
glad to see you um Christmas yeah what's
the problem on Christmas morning I'm up
really early trying to um prepare
vegetables or whatever can be done in
advance which is when I get really
stressed my solution to this of course
is be something simple and
something like a salmon on crout right
you can get prepped yes go off to church
return cook in the oven once that's cook
in the oven then you get the vegetables
on that will be done within the time the
salmon being cooked fantastic first and
foremost important get the salmon done
so it's just going to be um layers of
salmon sandwich together between the
fits be some butter saltana some ginger
some lemon and Thyme and the nice thing
about this particular dish it's quite
yeah it's quite festive there's the
salmon me skinned pin bone get the
butter paste this all over the
Sal we get the head and the tail yeah
opposite one another right so we lift up
the
salmon place that on there any
particular reason for that or this is so
it Cooks evenly this is short crust yeah
roll the pastry out get the salmon on
the pastry I'm going to use an egg wash
to stick this together I want you to
brush around the whole Rim nice leftt
over on your tray that goes in the
fridge excellent imagine it's Christmas
morning right Salmon's done yeah big
weight off your shoulders you're back
from church what's next check the oven
temperature yep whack it up and then get
the salmon yeah straight in and we're
going to do like a cream leak looks
fantastic at the table tastes amazing
and we're going to season with a little
bit of C powder right don't wor a little
bit wash on there please we don't want e
dirty leaks on Christmas day do
we no that'll spread like wildfire
around here yes the vica's wife got
dirty
leaks leaks into the
pan nice and it's lightly seasoned curry
powder yeah that was delicious cream in
the leaks right job done take it out
beautiful nice slowly it feels really
meaty that slice is beautiful I want you
to put the potatoes on all right main
ingredient on the left hand side of the
plate look at that cream Leakes there we
go now my dear vica's wife yes you're a
star you're the star happy Christmas w
wow wow wow what
[Music]
is oh yeah we have
this
Le massive Improvement that is
Che now how was that really good it's
very nice yes yeah and Ruth not too
stressed out very children fantastic
I've never said this to the Vicor before
but get out the kitchen yes and stay in
the church where you belong New Year's
resolution get back in the kitchen
absolutely Merry Christmas bye
bye hello
Ruth nice to see you Mark how are you hi
you well yeah fine thank you are you
feeling less scared now about cooking
are you done a bit you've done a bit
done a bit fantastic tried the pastry
again and it didn't stick to the pin oh
really plenty of flour that's great news
fantastic well done nice to see you take
it Merry Christmas good to see you thank
you
how's the turkey it's really nice yes
very nice um as you know it's been my
objective to get women back in the
kitchen and it's gone very well
thousands of requests not just from
Desperate Housewives but some from men
as well and one that really sort of I
suppose touched my heart was this
man Sharon happens to be in my opinion
the worst cook on the face of the Earth
she couldn't even make a piece of to are
burning it Gordon would you do me a big
favor I'm fed about having takeaway for
we delivered to my house teach you to
cook um what would I really like lamb
chops and Min sace he likes lamb chops
thank you very much teacher please
please I'm staring how you when did you
do that it was his play it was his
message to me to get how cute is he
listen that's one man I definitely don't
want to do upset come on Mrs Osborne
good to have you in the kitchen I can do
this I know I can now these are very
simple lamb chops pan onto the stove
this olive oil Touch of olive oil that's
right if I started off with butter it
will burn too quickly so it goes black
so little bit in nice hot pan rumors has
it okay that you didn't even realize a
how to work the oven and B what was in
your kitchen for is that true you
weren't that bad no my oven has always
had the instructions how to work it
still inside tape to the side of the
oven cuz I never turn it on no it was my
husband finding place for his boo cuz he
knew I'd never open it unbelievable he
used to have his everything everything
Ral morocc and black yes right I want
you to turn them now they're ready for
turning there's one finger on there like
that and turn it over now be careful you
don't don't don't don't Splash
yourself now my kids are constantly
banging on about me even at the age of s
six and five that I'm embarrass them
every time I go out do your kids ever
get embarrassed about some of the things
that you say and do please my kids have
been so I mean come on look at their mom
come on can you imagine the old man and
me turning up at parents night at school
I my kids went through hell and back
with us I mean their dad turning up in
Black Velvet and all his jewelry for
school
meetings and sports day yeah used to
fall asleep at parents meetings he'd be
there snoring yeah honestly but no
matter what this is the one thing no
matter what you look like what you do
every kid is still embarrassed so you
might as well be something to be
embarrassed about yeah I'm going to make
a little doggy bag now to take these
back best thing to do is keep them
wrapped in the tinfo okay put a little
mother butter in there yes and into the
oven and what would be best to serve
with that with that you know what a nice
mashed potato you know how to make a
mashed potato yeah you get powder and
you pour boiling water in it oh okay I
better come around Christmas day you
know that huh and have some help I'll
see you in minute yes next on the menu
is dessert time Hugh fly whing store
takes me on with his chocolate Chestnut
truffle cake suddenly all your
confidence is just sapping away and
Sharon Osborne is doing the judging one
of
them I really love and the other one I
do not like and J's kin finds out why we
should eat Christmas dinner every day
they're less likely to uh become
addicted to alcohol cigarettes drugs
they sitting there in front of the TV
eating their TV dinners basically
they're turning themselves into the
crackheads of
[Applause]
Tomorrow these tables for my wife yes
and children let's go one table I do not
want to [__] up come on let's go go go
up wakey
wakey playay down russle
yeah how M hi good good Holly what do
you think good good yes Megan nice M
Jack what do you think good and you like
the brown meat as well yeah Matilda what
do you think of Anthony nice does he
taste the way you thought he was going
to taste oh no I we should have baby so
you want to have turkeys back in the
garden again what about pigs in the
garden yeah pig
let what do you think about Matilda's
idea with chickens pigs is probably more
encouraging you happy with the pigs yes
Mommy said yes to the pigs that's
fantastic news I got to get back to the
kitchen my te give me yes we'll take
some for your teacher give me a kiss M
see you later I'm going back to work
back in the kitchen right listen clean
plates yes or no dessert yes what's for
dessert hopefully chocolate tart see you
later ice
cream no now this man H furly wooding
store is going to attempt to beat me
with his chocolate Chestnut cake no
chance you
reckon and what are you doing exactly
I'm going to do a a nice gooey chocolate
and Chestnut cake should be quite soft
and mousy in the middle one of the
things you could you can literally eat
it straight out of the oven as a as a
kind of hot chocolate pudding yeah good
and it you won't even manage to slice it
you just have to scoop it out oh nice
good luck good luck so I'm doing a very
simple straightforward chocolate tart No
Frills no spools no crem fresh no
vanilla chocolate tart with roasted
hazelnuts um we're going to make the
most amazing pastry um roll it out line
it in this um flan ring put the cream of
the milk onto boil add that to my little
chocolate buttons there's a very
well-known Elizabeth David chocolate
cake that uses ground almonds instead of
flour and keeps it lovely and moist and
quite fudgy in the middle this is really
based on that except I'm just using
Chestnut nuts cooked in a little cream
and milk mashed instead of the ground
almonds but really it's a tribute to to
her recipe but it's lovely at Christmas
cuz it's got the chestnuts in milk cream
up to the Bowl hazelnut prene on top of
the chocolate buttons and then quite
simply cream and milk onto the chocolate
and stir away now the thickening agent
of this particular tart are whole eggs
and what the egg does is as the cream
and the chocolate and the milk cook of
course the eggs help to set it
lightly whisk up the eggs and fold that
in the chocolate now I'm just going to
lightly toast my nuts now you you're
highly competitive aren't you even
though you're living in the countryside
you still have that Chef's competitive
streak in you don't you yeah I yeah I I
like to win Gordon whoa no it's all
right you thought it had all gone
horribly wrong for me there didn't you I
was hoping it had you know that c I'd
get fired from your kitchen so fast when
I look at my look at that look at oh my
God does that actually bring you out in
a sweat I'd be getting clipped around
the head if this was I probably am about
to be clipped by the head w't you find
from the River Cafe for being a messy
puppy yes in a word yes in the heck
there we
go we're baking the tar blind that means
we're going to line this ring with a
pastry and then bake that off first so
that's an added insurance policy that a
the pastry stays nice and crisp and B
all we have to do then is just cook the
chocolate filling so baking blind simply
means cooking it
twice you miss not being a professional
chef Running a Restaurant fulltime I
don't miss it at all cuz I was quite I
was quite a bad professional chef really
I just you know a bit like
Jamie I haven't got the discipline what
I do now I I enjoy very much you know
what we do in dorson isn't really a
restaurant it's more informal than that
it's about telling people where the food
comes from I have a great kitchen team
but it's sort of more of a cookery
School than a restaurant uhhuh and um
did you have long straggly hair at the
River Cafe I've always had long straggly
hair how many times a year do you wash
it I think I'm due for about once a
month seasonal seasonal did you have to
wear a hair that I could be due for my
pre-Christmas wash any day now you're
distracting me and you're making me over
whip the egg whites the thing about
folding in egg whites is never fold more
than you need to but you do have to get
it properly Incorporated which means
going deep to the bottom of the bowl and
just lifting the mix and that's it and
in it goes
that just goes in there for 25 minutes
the really important not to overcook it
so that you don't want it to dry out so
out nuts sprinkle the nuts at the
bottom chocolate in does look very good
we don't fill the tart right to the very
top here two3 of the way in open the
oven
door and then get the rest to your
mixture and top up the tart ah so that's
so you don't have to carry a really full
tart over to the oven exactly so it gets
really nice and
full that's obviously a very useful tip
for chefs who've been drinking too much
on Christmas Day
absolutely oh
[__] I dropped the cloth in it I've
already messed up my pudding are you
okay yeah I just went in to have a
little look and I dropped the cloth you
see that's where I got fired things like
that I dropped the cloth in the middle
of my cake I hope that's a clean one now
it's all down to [__] Sharon Osborne
you know that and you know I've got for
the first time in the FW series a proper
Chef in my kitchen so if there's any
time now that I really want to win it's
[__] today hug that's that's very
kind of you to describe me as a chef I'm
not a good loser you know that huh well
you better be I got I'm now in that
state of mind where I actually really
want to win serious yeah mine's in the
oven now it's got to go in there at 90°
for an hour and 10 to an hour and 15
minutes so it Cooks nice and slowly we
can't afford to turn up any higher than
90 95° otherwise it splits and separates
and I'm damned if I'm going to lose this
challenge for me the best thing about
Christmas of course the food the worst
thing about Christmas the leftovers now
I've come to see a bunch of guys that
just can't escape from that unwanted
turkey dast the prison may not be
renowned for its good food but like many
prisons it runs a professionally
recognized catering course to help
rehabilitate
inmates this is our kitchen Gardon again
with bars on there yes flipping this is
a real Hell's Kitchen [__] out there
are 3 and half th000 meals a day going
out of this kitchen 3 and half th000 Ms
a day yes not too concerned about my dog
tag I'm just concerned with the fact I
can get the [__] out of here in an
hour's time that's
all okay turkey leftover
Curry hello guys I'll be cooking with
Kieran baby
Daz and
Jacko I'm told they're the keenest cooks
on X-Wing serious BR has it h and you're
supposed to be a sort of Curry expert
yeah I won't say an expert no but you
love a curry I like it yeah Curry is the
most popular dish in the prison and is
also a great way to deal with leftover
Christmas turkey so I'm going to show
the men of X-Wing how to make a tie red
curry uh red chilies okay obviously uh
garlic
lemongrass and ginger um have you used
lemongrass before no no cut it in a half
okay yeah have a little
smell lovely that's very nice and
fragrant you smell that
before have a smell that lovely fresh
lemongrass beautiful I'll do it just cuz
it's it smells nice and sweet almost
like vanilla really nice and Lemony and
fresh and fragrant that lightens up the
curry so so this is where we make the
paste and their way to mix it now is
just get all the ingredients into a
blender we're doing it today with turkey
but you know this paste is great if
you're making a you know a fish curry
right there's your onion yes there's my
onion hold on hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on let's have a competition
you know how competitive chefs are yes
huh right what' you reckon we take him
at the first uh half or do you reckon
he'll be finished before me pretty good
he's pretty good right Knife Down the
whole thing chopped and ready to go
right that's set
go come on
kin first
[Applause]
half hold on a
minute
hey hey fancy a
job hey I'm serious fancy a job yeah not
25 quid a week Big Boy 25 quid a day
yeah when you
out 2007 okay 2007 give me a call and
come spend a day with me at the kitchen
okay yeah to make the curry we fry off
the onions add our curry paste and then
pour in coconut milk for a rich creamy
flavor nice then as it Cooks down we add
some Munch to for color and a bit of
bite what look all go called MCH to or
snow peas snow snow peas yeah it gives a
really nice sort of um texture slightly
sweet as well now the turkey meat and
mix it
through
nice keep on mixing that in my man back
up with the bowl um now with the rice
we're going to make a almost like um a
sticky rice and we got some cream
coconut here and the idea of course is
to get the rice cut up the coconut and
then just crumble that through there
like this y then from
there sprinkle the coriander through
there and what it does it makes a really
nice fragrant
rice okay um 30 minutes for the rice
once that's cooking um I'd love to go
have a look where you uh where you sleep
in the C
excellent cool [__] snore yeah huh
who snores the
loudest T me you
yeah who farts the
loudest [__] you
you might have it lie down that's mine
that's yours that's mine yeah [__] go
[__]
hard that's all right it's quite firm
then there that's all right let me just
think
[__] can you just dim those lights down
little please jacket um how's the
rice
lovely good should we get over there
yeah how are you big boy smells lovely
that was finished with fresh coriander
yeah good
man so what you recommend so
far right enjoy that yeahor beautiful
Merry Christmas big man Merry Christmas
to you Merry Christmas you thank not at
all let me say Merry Christmas Christmas
she good don't be late don't be late
look at that suddenly all your
confidence is just tapping away you're
absolutely [__] right that's ready
that's ready for Sharon now look it's
not quite firm but it that's good isn't
it you want it a bit gooey little bit
gooey that's right we oh that looks
beautiful it does look very very
nice homemade Villar ice cream looks
lovely Mr whitting St it does look
rather yummy that you know that slightly
concerned that it looks too [__] good
however it's going to be close isn't it
it's going to be very close they look
great they both look good don't they can
I just they do look fantastic can I just
have a little Slither of yours yeah of
course come mind just a
little all right please right have a
little bit of this one and the
cream it's very good it's incredibly
Rich okay John Baptist take them over to
Sharon hope she likes them M yes yeah
Andy listen remember if she doesn't
you're [__] yes you're out of a job I
know that yeah I fed up with [__]
losing hello Shon what have I got I'm
fine here we go so we have two desserts
yes so I let you try the first one m I
love desserts it's my favorite part of
the meal I love to me
too this is interesting mhm have you met
your mind on this one yeah yeah yeah
okay so this is design number
two
[Music]
compared to the first
one well let's leave it like
this one of
them I really love and the other one I
do not like I'm very excited I'm very
excited you've been working really hard
I've been having a lovely dinner I I
know I'm in a state of deep relaxation
about this hi huh how are you sorry
Sharon H very well this is very tense
you know that why well because well I
must say that I have heard that your
desserts have not been going down great
no rumor has it on the street yes
pressure on I am the chocolate Queen
good
goodes
good don't get too close already done a
lot of sucking up okay it's my turn put
us out our [__] misery put you out
his [__] misery the winner is which
one would you go back to a restaurant
for okay this is the one that's
absolutely and
completely [__]
wonderful Jesus Christ and what about
this one with the hazelnuts I would
never eat that that is [__] brilliant
Sharon Osborne I did love you I do love
your other oh my God this is wonderful
can I finish it please do can I spoon
feed you oh yes darling that was just
fabulous M hug Sharon yes darling may I
yes please what else do you cook here
what do you like Gordon may I what do
you like no you must come
on next on the menu is decision time I
give one of the comms the break of a
lifetime a job in my kitchens the person
that I'm going to offer a job to
is and jles Corin here's an amazing
excuse for eating in front of the Telly
there's always the excuse the dog always
eats something that's no good you eat in
front of the Telly cuz the dog at the
[Applause]
table welcome back to the f word now
time to find out what our diners thought
about the dessert did they agree with
Sharon's stupid verdict let's go
Russell light moist chocolaty gooey yum
it's great the cream that he made with
his with the T was fantastic very tasty
but a little bit too sweet and a bit too
rich Christmas is hard work but not for
our professional eater jles Corin he
wishes every day was Christmas
day well
wish
Christmas at this shopping center it's
been Christmas every day since the end
of October but what if it really worked
what if we had Christmas lunch every day
of the year Well presumably we'd all be
fat broke and miserable because
Christmas dinner is famously fattening
expensive and stressful but maybe we've
got it all wrong there's some convincing
evidence around that if we at Christmas
lunch every day we would in fact be
happier healthier and better off the
first excellent reason to have Christmas
lunch every day is that it's a meal you
prepare from scratch and not a ready
meal that means it's likely to be a lot
better for you well if you look at these
labels you see a list of additives and
preservatives and many of them are high
in salt and fat so you've got less
control over what you're eating uh so so
Christmas is better for us than what
people eat every day well if you think
about it tury breast without the skin is
a great lowfat source of protein you've
got carrots parsnips brussels sprouts a
great selection of vegetables helping
you to achieve your recommended f a day
but don't smother them in butter nor
salt that's the key steamed vegetables
lightly cooked then you've got your
potatoes well if you keep them large
keep the skin on explain if you keep
them large they absorb less fat so
actually you've got a lower fat potato
just by keeping the potatoes larger big
flowy not too crunchy potato with its
skin on that sounds delicious it
certainly does another potentially
worrying thing about eating Christmas
lunch every day is that it costs so much
money it is a big fation is and it is a
big meal so and do you think it's more
expensive than a normal meal I would say
yes I think you must go a little bit
extra at Christmas with a food
preparation everything else yeah but
that's where you're wrong because the
second reason to have Christmas lunch
every day is that it's actually a
bargain according to the Good
Housekeeping Institute your Christmas
food shop actually costs 40% less than
your normal food shop you go to the um
supermarket and you buy all these
ingredients and then when you take them
home you can cook um one big meal but
then you have leftovers everything else
this is the famous turkey Curry that
I've heard so much about exactly and
turkey sandwiches and turkey sule and
turkey cranberry that's right turkey
soup turkey pasta turkey rice risato
stir fries sandwiches well I think
that's about enough turkey the third
reason we should have Christmas lunch
every day is that it's a meal we eat at
the table with our family un likee the
rest of the
year where do you eat do you eat in
front of the Telly or yeah at the
moment some the dog get the
table there's always the excuse the dog
always eat something that's no good you
eat in front of the Telly cuz the dog at
the table they're not alone a recent
survey found that three qus of people
eat dinner in front of the TV and one in
five families only eat together once a
week so why does it matter then why why
why should we all sit around together
eating a a freshly prepared Meal instead
of sitting in front of the TV I don't
see why well consider sit down and
you're eting and you're watching
television then you're not speaking to
each other and communication is actually
the the way that we form strong bonds in
a family is there any proof I mean it
sounds a nice idea is there any proof
that it's true abely I mean there have
been loads of surveys into this
particular subject but there was a
really big survey into thousands of
teenagers and their parents by the
University of Colombia and that
stretched out over 10 years and it found
that it sort of improves children's um
skills communication wise the academic
skills they're less likely to become
addicted to alcohol cigarettes drugs
less like they become addicted to drugs
if they sit down to a square meal every
night yeah absolutely so sitting there
in front of the TV eating their TV
dinners basically they're turning
themselves into the crackheads of
Tomorrow well I suppose you could say
[Music]
that so there you have it eating
Christmas lunch every day could make you
happier healthier and better off and
best of all it might make your children
less likely to end up on
[Music]
crack right I got a present for you yes
um I long and hard and spent a fortune
on it and something that I've been dying
to sort of give
you mer Christmas they heavy
yes you
wanker excuse
me anything to get you more noticed now
make you look a bit taller try them on
hey I've already got a pair
not no yeah
thank you very
much give the audience a 12 give give a
little tail over there
give
yes tonight the fword Comm is I've been
fighting out for a job in my kitchen how
are you totally Shi in it didn't think I
did myself Justice well we all make
mistakes trust me how are you I I really
enjoyed being in the in the kitchen it
was um yeah it was the hardest it's
been it All Began 3 months go when I
scouted the country to find new chefs
with promise over a th000 applied WE
shortlisted 12 now what in the [__] do
we have here each week two comies have
gone head-to-head in the F-word kitchen
now two remain but only one of them will
get a job with me Russell he's creative
quietly confident and he has flare good
Well Done big boy yes but sometimes his
judgment is off taste it you tasted it
yes Che yeah and I think it's okay Chef
pass everything stop if I don't win I
would be absolutely gutted
Miller she's a fast learner confident
and she has an eye for detail one minute
Chef nicely SAU but big question is can
she cope with pressure having got this
far I really want to win this Miller
look at the bass that's going in the
bin where's your pass
there there's a lot of passion I hope
you realize by now um that I'm obsessed
with all things food people look at me
and tell me I'm crazy why do you want to
do this I because of the food because I
want to work with food because I want to
cook so you're not really just Posh tot
you really want to cook for a living I
really want to cook for a living you
really want to I really want to cook for
a living yeah describe your day today I
felt that I've done crap to be honest I
just didn't perform I felt you've got to
be able to take the pressure and when
the the [__] hits the fan it hits the
fan yeah and my reputation's at stake as
well if you can't handle this this
evening and you made so many fuckups
what's it going to be like when you're
in a real serious kitchen well that's
why I want have that opportunity to try
and get myself up to
scratch I feel that you're a person that
can actually eye me out anyway my
conclusion to you both is you've come a
long way I have to base my decision on
individuals that can absorb more be push
more and ones that can become stronger
under more pressure and the person that
I'm going to offer a job
to is Camila well done thank you and
well done to you yeah well done thank
you and well done to you yes don't give
up yeah keep cooking stay focused yes
and push yourself well done thank
you well done you do it oh love you my
girl thanks for watching the f word hope
you enjoyed your meal please please keep
cooking you've got to eat so you might
as well eat well happy plucking
Christmas as a chef oh oh [__] welcome
back [__] hell oh
that Fu my ass hurts welcome back to the
FW the food show that puts your mouth
[__] off that's [__] [__] [__]
OHS this health this is all about
[__] [__] sorry B flipid egg [__]
it [__] [__] that [__] I'm going a
little bit [__] loop the loop thank
you for watching
bollet